anything we've done like oh we have
these sustainable wind towers no we
don't we have these positive net entropy
devices that are going to just wear down
and we're going to have to rebuild them
so they're not Alternative Energy
they're rebuildables as Nate Hagen says
it's not that's all they are right so we
haven't yet used our big brains to
figure out how to Fashion something so
that it rebuilds itself over time right
that's what nature does everything it
does it's creating pockets of negative
entropy right and that's that's the rule
so so I can tell whatever the trees are
up to the tree has figured out a way to
do what it does and in 10,000 years you
know all things not going Supernova in
some spectacular fashion there'll be
trees here right it's so we have to
start thinking about how we how we
create things that are truly
regenerative it begins to me BR we have
to really appreciate understand energy
and how energy actually moves and flows
that we've been given this amazing once
in a species bequeathment right you know
there's there's complicated reasons why
we have these things called fossil fuels
like we have coal you know why we have
coal because plants developed lignan
before the back the the the um sorry the
fungi figured out how to break it down
there was this awesome period of several
you know hundred million years or so
where you know in the competing
chemistry of of Life One branch of Life
had figured out how to make stuff that
nobody had figured out how to eat holy
that
true hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast
I have the distinct pleasure and honor
of sitting this morning with Chris
Martinson who is a good friend of mine I
do not know how what fraction of our
audience on Dark Horse is aware of Chris
Martinson but if you're not aware uh
this is your lucky day because Chris is
an incredible person in fact Chris you
don't know this but you are I'm not a
religious person but you are one of very
few things in the universe that makes me
wonder if there is a God
because during The Madness of coid we
were granted a kick-ass toxicologist in
the form of you and the idea that the
dissidents of coid would have a kickass
toxicologist there to address the
difficult toxicological questions
surrounding repurposed drugs and
vaccines that was a gift from from above
so in any case Chris welcome to
Darkhorse I am uh and a little
frightened about where we might have to
go today in light of events in the
world well thank you for such a a
magnanimous introduction and and it's a
mutual admiration society and uh it's
it's a world you know I'm really glad
for Co because it allowed me to find you
I don't know if I would have
necessarily um otherwise in the way that
we have and it allowed me to find other
people who really are are able to in in
the term you use the heterodox thinking
but it's more than that it's it's a it's
there's a certain Fidelity a and a an
approach to information that's really
important not that we get it right all
the time but that we have this this what
I consider to be the science I was
raised on that I I loved that I was
offended when Co came along and it all
went out the window which is science is
it you know yeah it's a noun but but
it's an approach it's a way it's a way
of going about things which by its very
root depend on things being falsifiable
which demands that you ask questions
right and so that's what I felt you did
exquisitly well in taking people through
how you get to that thinking process and
and I don't I don't know what the truth
is but man I've got a BS detector that's
good you know if not you know
exceptional so I just put that to use
during Co that was my I I was fueled by
a little curiosity and a little anger at
what happened to my beloved
science or what I thought it was
apparently I had a myth about it you did
a brilliant job during coid and just to
put a little more flesh on these bones I
don't remember exactly when during the
coid madness uh we found each other and
met we very quickly after I I think I
heard you um on one of your Peak
Prosperity podcasts that's uh how the
public is most likely to be aware of
you but I I heard you say some things
and and I have a just a little rubric I
use to find truly important
thinkers our first sponsor for this
episode is Vivo barefoot shoes made for
feet Vivo was one of our very first
sponsors and they remain one of our
favorites everyone should try these
shoes most shoes are made for someone's
idea of feet not Vios Vios are made by
people with feet who know how to use
them and word is spreading people often
approach us because of the vios we are
wearing and they ask if they're as good
as we say they are they are these shoes
are every bit as good as you've heard
here at Darkhorse we love these shoes
they are Beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're fantastic our feet
are the product of millions of years of
evolution humans evolve to walk move and
run Barefoot modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted foot function
and are contributing to a Health crisis
people move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
enter Vivo
Barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes are
designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60% in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear there a certified be
Corp that is pioneering regenerative
business principles and their Footwear
is produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild upon it go to viob
barfoot.co.nz
paleo Valley paleo Valley makes a huge
range of products from supplements like
fish row and organ complex grass-fed
bone broth protein and superfood bars
everything we've tried from them has
been terrific including their golden
milk made with tons of turmeric but
today we're going to talk about beef
sticks the beef in these delicious
snacks comes from small American-owned
Farms that practice rotational grazing
paleo Valley beef sticks are 100%
grass-fed and finished entirely organic
and naturally
fermented grass fed beef is more
nutritious than grain fed beef in many
ways including that it contains more
calcium magnesium pottassium zinc
phosphorus beta katene and iron and it's
utterly
delicious but if you're thinking paleo
Valley's beef sticks are like slim gyms
you've got this wrong for one thing
unlike slim gyms paleo Valley's beef
sticks contain no mechanically separated
chicken parts for another paleo Valley's
beef sticks are actually good for you
ingredients hiding in most beef sticks
and jerky include MSG hormones
hydrogenated o oils brominated vegetable
oil which if you're wondering was first
patented as a flame retardant now it's
in a lot of food but you won't run into
it if you buy paleo Valley furthermore
unlike other meat snacks paleo Valley
uses natural fermentation to preserve
its beef sticks this gives the sticks a
long shelf life without the use of
harmful acids or chemicals and with the
added benefit of contributing to a
healthy
gut paleo valy beef sticks are also
ketofriendly and make a great protein
Rich snack to grab when when you're on
the go like running out the door for a
meeting to do a podcast or to go on a
bike ride paleo Valley doesn't cut
Corners they Source only the highest
quality ingredients and are passionate
not only about human health but also
about environmental restoration and
Animal Welfare they are family-owned
company try paleo Valley's beef sticks
today you'll be glad you did head over
to paleo
valley.com Darkhorse for 15% off your
first order it's like this you know I'm
a as you know I'm somebody who thinks
about a lot of different issues there
are places where I know very little and
my thinking is undoubtedly crude and
there are other places where I know a
lot um but enough of it is just not it's
not borrowed from anywhere so if I have
overlap with somebody if I hear somebody
talking on a topic where I've spent you
know a few months pondering the various
puzzle pieces and trying to put together
some model of what's going on I can
often listen to somebody else who's done
that independently and I don't know
whether they're telling what they're
telling me is right but if it is
consistent with whatever model I've
built I can say this person's for real I
know that they didn't get that from
somewhere and I know that it is that
they are putting puzzle pieces together
in a a difficult realm in a coherent way
and you just set off that detector like
Gang Busters across multiple topics so
anyway we got in touch and I I don't
know how you would describe it but would
say we found that there is a
tremendous overlap between us in
our I would
say
values across many domains you know we
both have a deep relationship with uh
with nature that goes Way Beyond the
analytical just a real desire to be um
surrounded by it to for it to be healthy
it is non stop thought-provoking to both
of us we are disturbed by changes that
we have seen in our lifetime that we can
personally attest have occurred that
indicate that the world is getting uh
broken
biologically so there was tremendous
overlap at that level and then there's a
discovery that actually you're a very
different human being in terms of how
you have lived your life and
accomplished the things you've
accomplished right almost no overlap in
terms of uh the me mechanism of doing
things in the world you know I I uh
managed to get through a PhD program
because I had an adviser who thought
highly of me and was powerful in the
department but I don't have the skills
to just get through these kinds of
systems and I think you're expert at
it well I did make it through a PhD
program but that was that was a a a a
just a huge amount of work and is and I
know how much work it took and you know
I get that um and I remember it I think
pretty clearly but the amount of work
I've put into say this this this work
called the crash course where I I skip
across some surfaces do a systems level
analysis of economy energy environment
looking for how these things interrelate
I didn't know anything about systems
systems analysis complex systems
exponential growth monetary systems but
I'm just curious right so so the tools I
learned and how you go about
achieving something in in a PhD program
and by the way you can get to the
frontier of knowledge in the biological
science is what four months of study you
know it's like there's a lot we don't
know you can it's not as I would I'm
glad I didn't try it in Humanities I
doubt I would have I would have made it
right you know well there is no Frontier
there's like a hologram there's Shadows
on the wall and uh so yeah it's it's not
the same thing there is a real Frontier
in biology but unlike uh the other hard
Sciences because it's a complex adaptive
system um
it's very early in our accumulation of
knowledge about it so the frontier isn't
isn't as far away as you think yeah and
this is how I think what we're alike is
is despite the differences in background
is we're both very curious and we're
both we both know that there's no such
thing as a singular point of study like
you can't you can't study biology
without studying chemistry it's not
possible right it's all about electrons
going from a higher oxidative state to a
lower whatever okay and then once you
understand chemistry maybe you have to
know a little bit about physics right
and then it gets into Material Science
like everything touches everything and
so I've noticed that in you as well it's
like you know if we're going to have a
conversation you have these phone
conversations where it's like it there's
there it's a really amazing beautiful
world that's just full of fun in
adventure and it's just wildly
complicated
and older I I'm GNA correct you on that
one because that distinction ends up it
sounds like syn yeah
complex right it has emergent behaviors
right yeah exactly which which means you
just have to observe Eevee and I were
having this conversation just last night
um as we do about what what is
consciousness like what is it because we
use it but what is it and the closest I
can come to is consciousness is is the
act of
observing it's it's
awareness so Consciousness is awareness
because otherwise I mistake the thoughts
I have in my head as Consciousness or
not that computers have thoughts in the
sense of 1 plus one is two and the
capital of Mississippi is what you know
those kinds of thoughts no no
consciousness is observing so so that's
what um life has been to me and that's
what my blessed science was was it was
observing all right hold on I want I
would like to leave Consciousness and I
would like us to come back to it make
sure that we don't miss it entirely in
this podcast but I want to uh I think
sort of feels to me like a topic for the
end not the beginning um good the I want
to go back something just clicked for me
in hearing you discuss the connections
between fields and Science and it's
something it's kind of been on a back
burner for me for years and suddenly I
think I know what it
is I use I usually use the analogy of a
tropical forest I'm a tropical biologist
by
training
and I always tell people that the thing
the tropical forest is trying to tell
you there's nowhere to actually start
the discussion you can walk into a
tropical forest and you can say you know
the way to understand this place is
trophic levels and you can use trophic
levels to analyze what you see around
you but it's not the only rubric you can
also you know talk about the uh
proximity to the canopy you know the all
of the energy that drives the system
comes in at the top and it very quickly
gets absorbed by all of these ferocious
iously powerful competitors for light so
that when you get to the forest floor
you've got 1% of the light so you could
use you know where you are in the race
to capture energy that has been thrown
off of the Sun that would be another
rubric you could use you could do it
phog gentically you could start talking
about these creatures and which ones are
basil in other words there there are
lots of rubrics you could use none of
them are
incorrect they all reveal different
things and they all fail to reveal other
things and what you really want is some
piece of all of them but but the basic
point is
look I have a principle which is all
true narratives must reconcile if two
things are true there's some way that
they live in the same universe at the
same time and if you can't see how they
could coexist there's something you
don't know yet or you've got one of them
wrong at least one but anyway my point
is what you really want if you want to
understand a tropical forest and we
don't understand them yet but if you
want to understand as you point out at
the frontier you want to understand
everything we do understand so that you
can figure out what we might learn by
going a little farther well there's no
right place to start any place you start
as long as it's valid is going to be
connected to the thing that you might
ultimately want to learn and the
punchline of this whole uh
exploration
is what you need and what ukis have in
Spades is a nonlinear
mind and I do not believe that a
nonlinear mind is inherent to all
Sciences in other words sometimes to do
certain things in chemistry you may need
a very linear mind right to understand
the way orbitals build up on top of each
other and their implication for chemical
reactions that is a series of pieces of
nuances that build on each other in such
a way that you get a model that is
predictive out to some level where we
can say what happens if we put these
reactants in this set of conditions
right so I think the world is in part
failing
because we have not properly understood
that uh complex adaptive
systems we group them with the other
Sciences because the method is
technically the same for studying them
this hypothetico deductive
falsificationist approach but the
subject matter is very different than
chemistry or physics and it's different
because the stuff of biology has an
objective right evolutionary
evolutionarily the creatures are
actually trying to accomplish something
they don't know that they're trying to
accomplish something the thing that
they're trying to accomplish is not in
and of itself interesting but things
that are trying to accomplish something
behave differently than objects that
don't
care an atom doesn't care whether it
becomes integrated into a compound but a
creature does care whether it escapes
its
predator and in any case what I what I
would say is I think a lot of
people have a linear scientific mind it
may be a very good one but very few
people jump the Gap to a nonlinear
scientific mind that can remain rigorous
in a highly complex landscape of things
where most of the information you would
like to have is not
available and anyway you do a brilliant
job of this and I have appreciated you
greatly for your capacity in this in
this regard well thank you thank you
it's um uh I've I've tried to devolve
what I do um and break its pieces down
but one of them is um I don't have my
identity wrapped up in my
conclusions it's actually very powerful
place to be and I'm easily I can red
team blue team anything you want me to
take somebody else's position I'll argue
it for them you know maybe off times
better than they will right you you want
me to be Peter hotz for the day I'll do
it right so in doing that I I I discover
where my where my own cracks are so I
actually really like debate I like being
challenged um you know there's only a
few challenges I've sort of given up on
is there's nothing more to learn there
the Flat Earth people right I don't have
anything to gain there um y the no virus
crowd I'm not gaining anymore honing of
my argumentative abilities there um so
there's certain places where I've sort
of put it off but almost everything else
is up for grabs you know well I will
actually let me let me Steelman the flat
earthers and the nov virus people
despite the fact that I I have reached
more or less the same conclusion as as
you have right I can establish that the
world is not flat it's not that hard
anybody who's faced time zones has at
least a beginning of the mechanism for
understanding there's no there there in
flat earthland
um but I have become aware
that the foundation of what people
believe they know has
gotten thin to the point
of tissue
paper that is to say if you take an
educated person a person who appears to
know a great many
things their understanding of how it is
that they come by that knowledge is
almost non-existent in other words what
would have to be true for that
conclusion that you believe is a fact to
change for you right what would you have
to
know that would cause you to reverse
your position on whether or not people
went to the
moon they don't know all they know is
that basically everything comes down to
uh an appeal to Authority that people
smarter than me have told me that this
is
true and I'm sure they would have
spotted it if it wasn't and that is no
Comfort whatsoever it really shouldn't
be it is it it in other words an
intelligence that is composed of facts
that are entirely received from
authorities is not the same kind of
object as an intelligence that can
bootstrap its way in a total absence of
knowledge through observation through
the scientific method or some analog of
it
and I call this I call the place we are
in history a cartisian crisis because I
believe that Dart actually explored this
problem explicitly and in fact left us
an artifact that tells us something
about what he concluded and it's it's a
crude artifact but deart upon
realizing that he could not establish
most of what he thought were facts on
the basis of some personal test that he
had run that he was apparently
proceeding from Authority almost across
the board I think he kind of panicked
and he said well what is there anything
I can establish myself just me and what
he came up with was the most important
proof of all which is really not a good
proof right I think therefore I am Kad
ergosum I find it almost embarrassingly
circular but the reason I say it's
important is that if you cannot accept
that one on
faith you're
done the right way to to proceed is to
recognize hey there's a flaw in my
thinking at the very ground floor I
can't even establish that I exist how do
I know I exist because I'm thinking okay
that's weak sauce right there but the
basic point is I've got two choices at
that branch of the tree I can either
spend the rest of my life failing to do
better than that proof and not in the
end establishing that I exist in any way
better than deart did or I can say you
know what weak as that is probably right
if it's
wrong I don't really have a shot at
anything useful anyway so the waste is
small because even though I will waste
my life I'm pretty much guaranteed to do
that anyway so I might as well assume I
exist and I am capable of observing the
universe around me this isn't a trick
it's not a simulation I'm not a brain in
a jar being fed info to see what I will
do right I must actually exist in the
universe and I can go about checking
stuff out from there I can make a lot of
progress so anyway uh I feel like I'm
talking too much but my point is
Humanity has lost touch with how you
established things and almost everybody
is proceeding almost entirely from
received wisdom from unreliable
sources and it has made
us foolish at a level that is putting us
in grave
danger so I
appreciate anybody who can bootstrap
their way from no knowledge to
something useful predictive
uh something
insightful and uh
anyway again this is something I find
you very strong on you are capable of
walking into Landscapes where you're not
expert and figuring out well what where
would I want to
start um and you teach yourself which is
really what we should all be
doing well on this one subject um and
thank you for for laying it out this way
it I I'm deeply interested in how people
come to believe in the Flat Earth thing
I I I'm interested in this cartisian
crisis we're in the midst of because I'm
suffering through it right now which is
I don't know what to trust anymore trust
has been just comprehensively across the
board broken for people right at at all
different levels right I mean you have
Harvard University scoring the lowest on
free speech out of all the major
universities right and that's supposed
to be our that's supposed to be our our
ultimate like experience you have uh
Harvard still sort of demanding that
people take vaccines which is a a
cognitive error so profound like these
this is they're training our Future
Leaders this
badly right isn't that their way of
telling you don't send your kid here to
get smarter because the opposite is
going to happen for sure they ought to
pay you 80 grand for the for the
privilege of ruining your kid your kid
stup yeah yeah something like that but
but when it comes to the to the Flat
Earth piece though um I have two
problems with it the first is that it's
very easy to observe that it's not true
athenes did this what you know how many
thousands of years ago with a stick in
the sun right and having somebody walk a
long way um so so model in that out it's
easy but if you ever been on a sailboat
and watched another one disappear over
the horizon if you've ever gone high up
up in a plane or a or on a mountain
you've seen curvature right there's lots
and lots and lots of input feeds to this
brain in a jar that would suggest I can
falsify this right and yet it's still
there and so my concern is that this is
one of those ideas that gets put out
there and is sort of enabled by somebody
who's interested in tracking how these
things spread and thinking you know how
they can stuff CU that you know in the
in the aftermath of say the Lina fires I
had a lot of people coming in with blue
roofs and energy weapons all this I was
trying to explain to them that no no
wind go the effects of wind go up with
the cube of the speed it's a thing 30
miles an hour wind is totally different
from 40 which is completely different
from 50 and by the time you're at 70 you
can get some weird effects right this is
burned but this isn't because the wind
was blowing that way right so all of
that um but through all of that I was
convinced of something though which was
that that incident watching and tracking
how these people's ideas came in
somebody was pushing some buttons I know
that there was somebody in a cubicle at
some sop Place tracking all of this
monitoring how things spread watching
the memes propagate pushing little
nudging all of that because it's too
juicy of a moment I I'm I'm of the
belief structure now that every single
major event that has that focus of of
the system to like this Focus on this
that it's not it's not organic anymore
it's it's increasingly less organic well
now you've completely screwed this up
because what you've done is you've said
that people's tendency to take a natural
event and impose on it dark Forces and
uh secret weapons is them overfitting a
bad hypothesis and they're doing it
because dark Forces are hoping to map
their sens making capacity in the way
ideas spread so you've basically um
you've moved the conspiracy that people
see into a layer that they're not
thinking about and uh you know I must
tell you there
are I don't
know I don't know what gets you into
trouble anymore but look I got questions
about lahina based on things I think I
can observe that don't make sense to me
I don't know what to make of you know
I'm fully aware that fire behaves in a
nonlinear fashion based on things like
wind and that the wind was uh a dominant
factor and no that was nobody's
plan I don't know what the hell happened
but there's also some metallurgical
stuff that doesn't add up to me I'm
waiting for somebody to just simply lay
it out so I get it maybe you're the the
person to do it but um but anyway let's
put that aside for I I do have one quick
thing on that if you want to finish that
thought process that a lot of the things
where we saw um cars uh experiencing
thermal events that felt too hot I don't
know this for sure but I would want to
check the brands and models of those
because a lot of those have aluminum
magnesium blocks those are fine but if
they catch on fire yeah aluminum and
magnesium together get right gets very
hot got it got it um there's still weird
stuff and it could be that somebody's
playing me and they're trying to see
whether I'll you know pop and say
something stupid but um let's go back to
the Flat Earth thing for a second I like
the Flat Earth because it's almost the
one of these things that I can chase
down to bedrock right as you point out
there's a bunch of stuff that you as an
as an individual a modern individual who
you know not everybody has mountains
within walking distance but everybody
can get to a mountain these days
and uh everybody can take an airplane I
mean not everybody but almost everybody
can take an airplane um time zones and
telephone calls allow you to establish
things and the fact is it's just the
most parsimonious explanation that we
live on a globe and not a dis and um
blah blah blah blah blah but I think it
is tremendously valuable to put yourself
through the
exercise that's the thing that is
missing and so I wanted to steal
man
a I'm almost hesitant to to mention this
but there's a very troubling person that
I interact with sometimes a guy named uh
Owen Benjamin you aware of
him
comedian
um smart
guy uh claims not to believe any of this
stuff right including Flat Earth uh he
is a he is an avowed flat earther um but
he I don't know that he's serious about
it I think his point and mind you I have
you know he I am told he is a dangerous
person to interact with I interact with
him anyway because I think part of what
he's doing is
valuable what it is is that he is
forcing
people to confront the degree to which
they cannot even defend beliefs that
they would swear they hold for
analytical reasons his point I think and
he's not said this so maybe I'm imposing
something on him that he's he's not
actually doing but I think his point is
i Owen Benjamin as a smart person am
capable of defeating your argument for
something you're certain of and that's
on you the fact that you can't defeat me
in an argument about Flat Earth doesn't
say anything one way or the other about
whether the Earth is flat it says
something about the weakness of your
belief
structure um so in any case I don't know
what to do with this but if I'm thinking
we are in a cartisian crisis because
everybody has accepted almost everything
on the basis of authority which is not
it's not that we have any choice about
that there's not no individual can go
around establishing all of the
scientific principles you would need in
order to reason but the that most people
can't establish
anything is a major vulnerability it
makes us um superstitious and
manipulable at a level that is
intolerable given our
power so the cartisian crisis is a
problem you're pointing to dark Forces
that may wish to take advantage of our
feeble analytical capacity is uh well
taken and I think that those
who are to the extent that anyone is
attempting to call our attention to the
defects in our belief
structures I don't know that that's a
bad thing I think that that's probably a
good thing and I wish ow and Benjamin
would mature and do this in a more
responsible way because it comes across
as Petty and
trolling but um but we all have to
become
aware I don't remember what obs ation it
was oh it was the observation of what
the eclipse reveals about the splotches
of light that we see every day through
the trees um the eclipse reveals that
those are all images of the sun um and
what that caused me to
think uh was it yesterday or the day
before um was that it's like a fractal
Plato's Cave yes there's the cave in
which the Shadows on the wall are being
used to lead you to understand a world
that isn't but then you get out of the
cave and you're in a different cave
right it's still Shadows on the wall
it's a different kind of Shadows and um
anyway people need to think more about
what the basis of their comprehension is
in order to become cautious enough to
proceed intelligently and they just they
don't do
it well this is this is a fascinating
conversation because it gets to the the
the very core of what what I think I'm
doing so originally I was in the
business of sharing data with people
because I'm one of those people data
works on and I it I'm a quick learner
eventually I you it took me years to
figure out that's not how other people
are wired so I was like oh okay what
what is this about and then I realized
okay I should have figured this out
quicker it's that we're narrative
machines right and and you know we used
to sit around the campfire and tell
stories and those stories are immensely
powerful and they encapsulate stuff you
know to the point that thousand years
later people could have not have seen
seen a tsunami but it's encoded in their
in their story structure so they know
what to do when the water goes out and
they run up uphill right so it's amazing
how powerful that is and so that led to
another you know so narratives are are
one layer and I thought we were at the
narrative layers about the story so I
worked on how do we tell the stories
right so that's what I do in this book I
tell stories about you know exponential
growth just trying to embody it and that
was genius but I didn't realize where it
was and I finally stumbled across a book
um by Loff uh George Loff and it's about
metaphor
and I'm I'm only halfway through it so
I'm no expert but it's just ringing all
my bells that in fact we operate at the
level of metaphors and the narratives
are are a verbal cognitive layer on top
of that but what's a metaphor and so a
metaphor is a concept but really it's an
they make a very strong argument it's an
embodied concept that in fact it comes
through whatever this other sensory
stuff is and so we have these metaphors
as Concepts right and the concept is is
vague but really powerful it drives a
lot so one of the one of the pieces that
they um put in there was about well the
metaphor for an argument what is our
metaphor you know in Western discourse
an argument its metaphor is war right
we're going to have a battle of the
minds I'm going to you know defeat your
your you know Silly stance or whatever
it is it's it's war and and so it
creates this this whole thing where a
lot of people will shy away from it
because we don't like conflict right an
argument is conflict it's War winners
and Los there's blood um and he said but
what if you're there are cultures out
there where they had um argument was the
metaphor for it was a dance and the idea
of a dance is that two parties are
trying to come up with the best possible
choreography given the tempo and the
music and the air that night right it's
it's a whole different metaphor but I
realized that our core metaphors is
these are the things that I this I'll
link this back to the cartisian crisis
this I think is the thing the soul
sickness that we're facing is that our
core metaphors that we've lived by for
thousands of years are now
broken be fruitful and multiply have
dominion over the Earth these are all
good things until you hit six or seven
billion people then it starts to become
little asically uhoh kind of stuff
potentially right so so you know our
whole economic model is based on
infinite growth our whole dominion over
the Earth is clearly run its limits if
you care about things like insects and
400 million year old food chains and
things like that right um it's clear we
have problems in order to get ourselves
cognitively organized and rallied around
them we have to have a way of of
articulating them and talking about them
without it tripping all of our amydala
brain stem landmines where you know
can't do that because it's too
challenging right that I think is one of
the Prime tensions we have right now and
then is an overlay on top of all of that
we do have people monkeying around with
our cognitive landscape conducting fifth
generation Warfare specifically to
Target our ability to make sense of
things so we're already at a sense Mak
like um bottleneck you know we have a we
have some important decisions to make
and we have people trying to hobble us
even further I I have I I completely
disagree with what they're doing at this
moment in
time yeah I want to introduce two things
that's a lovely uh exploration there and
I so totally agree first of all metaphor
Loom large for me I don't know if you do
or don't know but um I have this model
uh uh called metaphorical truth which I
use to explain to people why uh
religious belief is what it is that
basically there's lots of stuff that you
cannot fully um
understand but you can present a
narrative that causes people to behave
as if they understand it so for
example uh the Lord does not um to
tolerate people [__] in Camp right
he finds that disgusting and you do not
want to anger the Lord so don't do it
right that's a 2,000 year old mechanism
more than 2,000 year old mechanism for
getting people to behave as if they
understand the germ theory of
disease right so it's a metaphor and so
I say it's literally false it's not that
there's actually a deity who actually
has gust and that but if you behave as
if there is you do better than if you
behave as if that's just a old wife's
tail so anyway metaphorical truth LMS
large to me and I know that language if
you actually if you look at the what the
linguists tell us um that our languages
are basically entirely built of
metaphors some of them so long dead that
we don't even spot them as metaphorical
the the encoding is just remote to us
they're just words but they started out
as metaphors so we do think
metaphorically and those metaphors are
not inherently
literal um they overlap literalness but
the place that this goes crazy is when I
look at the biology
textbook it's also composed of metaphors
some of them there are places where we
understand biology well enough that you
have almost a literal description in
front of you it's cartoonified to make
it simple enough for a student to
understand it you know the picture of
the neuron has 20 dendrites instead of a
thousand because it's very hard for the
mind to process what it would mean for a
neuron to have a thousand dendritic
inputs um
but you know what what you need is a
heat map you need to be able to read the
biology textbook and you need to have a
color coding that says how metaphorical
is this which I am currently reading
right and it would range across the
entire map there's gobbly G in that in
that textbook that just is not right
it's the best we've got at the moment
but it's just not even close enough to
correct to treat it as factual and then
there's other stuff that is so close to
factual that it's you know it's
basically there and if you understood
that that was what the book was doing to
you the book is like look here's the
best model we can give you in order so
you can move forward and discover what
we don't yet know
right some of this is going to be
nonsense but to sort of accept it you
know um and some of this stuff is really
the real thing um so you should actually
put more weight on that ice don't don't
put so much weight on this ice but that
ice can take it right if you did that
you would create much better minds but
because the book reads like an
encyclopedia of biological truths it
just confuses people they don't
understand that we are very early in in
this uh um process of comprehending
especially you know much more so than
with chemistry chemistry there is a
point at which we can't predict what
takes place but that's a pretty you got
to get pretty exotic reagents and
conditions before you reach that place
where we don't have a pretty good
understanding of what's likely to happen
right you got to get into nuclear
interactions for example you know um but
in biology no it's most of it what what
do we what fraction of what we might UL
know of biology that do we know
now I don't know 5% you know it's early
days it's not
95% um so anyway metaphor matters a lot
and but here's the here's the other
punchline to that little
riff so in in my in my book that uh
Heather and I co-authored in our book
The the title is the hunter gatherers
Guide to the 21st century but I sort of
as much as I really like that title I
sort of regret not type titling it hyper
novelty the idea of hyper novelty is
that human beings our specialty is
dealing with novel circumstances and
coming up with mechanisms to profit in
them in the midst of them um it's what
we do and it's the reason that more than
any other creature that has ever lived
our evolutionary information
our evolving content is not housed in
our genomes it is housed in
our cognitive layer which has passed
along as culture which is innovated
through Consciousness which we will get
back to later but the point is hey what
creature adapts really really well to
new stuff that its ancestors never saw
that's human beings that's our specialty
right that's what we're good at but our
rate of change is so high that we cannot
keep up with it even our amazing
capacity to adapt is outstripped by our
rate of technological change and so we
are constantly using tools that are
inappropriate for the environment we
find ourselves in we're just we're a
fish out of water perpetually like
flopping from boat to boat um and anyway
the point is you're I love the idea that
you borrow from Lake off that
war is a metaphor that is deeply rooted
in our discussions of
circumstances where we have conflicting
interests but not
danced dance is not always the right
metaphor but sometimes it's exactly the
right metaphor why because dance
actually does
contain the um the ability to explore
the tension
between the
cooperative and the competitive right
who are the Ultimate Dance Part Partners
they are romantic Partners those
romantic Partners have potentially
tremendously overlapping interest but
never perfectly right and that you know
one of the greater insights of
evolutionary biology that we picked up
in the latter half of the 20th century
was about these places where we see two
creatures who have great alignment but
not perfect alignment and it predicts
all kinds of things from you know uh
conflict between siblings to Mourning
sickness and pregnant mothers right this
is something you need to be able to talk
about situations in which um I mean
let's put it this way let's we we are
going to come to the Middle East here at
some point inevitably I believe um but
as as
uh morally wrong as some will take it
that I would even say this uh following
the events of two Saturdays
ago
the the Palestinian
people and the Israeli people have a
terrible conflict of
interest they also potentially have a
great alignment of interest if you look
at these two populations and you
say what actually if we were to look at
their well-being not just in the present
but for a thousand years going for going
into the
future they have an interest in finding
a stable way to
coexist and
surely to
collaborate now that's a hard thing to
say at this moment collabor this is not
a moment to be thinking in terms of
collaboration because the crime against
the Israeli public was so
diabolical that talking about about
collaborating with these people is
almost
[Music]
um it's a kind of heresy in some ways
it's disrespectful of the dead
but it is also a fact that we Face a
future in which we may not find a
mechanism for these two populations to
work out their conflict of interest and
proceed forward through time hopefully
collaboratively because it's better for
everybody it's better for planet Earth
it's better for the Israelis it's better
for the
Palestinians
so I love your point are we missing a
metaphor that allows us to even think
about the puzzle properly and my sense
is because of hyper novelty we have a
language that is hobbling us in our
ability to even articulate what it is
that we face I think that is exactly
correct I I love the way you frame that
um Let me let me connect a piece in
there for that for me which is here's a
myth we have and this is one I battle
all the time I'll tell people about hey
here's the latest data on oil here's how
much coal we have here natural gas
here's uranium here are the needs of the
world here's the fastest growing and
people go you're forgetting about this
they hold up their smartphone right and
the metaphor for them is that this
represents human Ingenuity and progress
and and there are things Chris that you
haven't thought about that we're going
to invent that you don't know about yet
right I call it technological hopium
because I'll be right there as soon as
we figure out how to wrestle free energy
out of zero point fine you know y but
until then I'm I'm a Missouri guy you
got to show me right but they hold it up
like this is some Article of Faith and
and and I sit here and I I have I'm like
well let me tell you a story I love GPS
if I go to Boston or some City I don't
know I wouldn't think of doing it
without my GPS I love GPS it's great GPS
ruined our oceans because it used to be
some guy would in his crew would take
off from Glouster and they dead wrecking
out for six maybe seven hours depending
on tide and wind and they drop their
Nets and they drag around for a while
well now as soon as GPS came along they
would leave off 6 in to the left
literally of where they left off last
week and just keep scraping and and they
destroyed the whole thing so the
technology exceeded our human capability
to really Master it and that's just GPS
right you know now we have these tools
of persuasion and they're all excited
look at these things we can do and I
will submit to you they will discover or
we're going to I guarantee you we're
going to discover that these actually
screwed an entire generation I am
thankful right that I grew up at a time
that these weren't available cuz these
would have wrecked my childhood I
guarantee it I'm no better you know I
I'm not here to cast judgment I'm just
telling you I'm thankful I grew up at a
time where my life consisted of being
kicked out of the house it's when the
sun was up and coming home hopefully
when the sun went down for dinner and
that was you know otherwise I was out
there with my buddies doing stuff right
and and so again the technology it is a
two-edged sword but I think our myth
ology our our metaphor for it is
progress is good and this is progress
and it's a broken metaphor it doesn't
work I me the evidence is everywhere and
I'm surprised how many people literally
can't see it and that's one of the fun
things about metaphors when you hold one
it can prevent you from seeing
something that's right in front of you
you know it's oh it's an astonishing
thing don't I know it first of all I
feel the same way about about the phone
and many other things I mean even I I
love digital photography I'm a
photographer I love to capture nature
it's it's a it's an addiction um and
digital
is there's just no comparison right the
difference between trying to nail that
shot on a roll of 36 expensive pieces of
silver coated uh
whatever right I I don't I don't
miss the uh uh shooting on film I don't
do it anymore ever however I am grateful
for every minute I spent under those
constraints because it taught me a hell
of a lot about the way the world Works
including stuff that went on to inform
my understanding of biology right the
trade-offs in a a camera that shoots
film taught me how to think about
trade-offs in a way that I then
extrapolated into the the realm of
creatures um so anyway I I gu this and
the phone I even find that the
capacities I did develop as a young
person in a world without such devices
are growing crude you know on a day you
know when I somehow don't have a phone
because it's died or something like that
it's amazing how much I'm depending on
it and I don't even realize I'm doing it
which is uh which is very very
frightening um but yes developmentally
it has been a disaster but I want want
to point one other thing out
um I have been I've never been to
burning
man I have
been almost unwilling to
go because I'm so annoyed by the myopia
that people who think it's a great thing
appear to have about what kind of great
thing it might be it's not that I'm
against a festival it's not that I'm
against people taking a week or whatever
it is and throwing off the rules and
putting art first or whatever I'm not
against any of that I think there's
potentially great value in it and and I
would ordinarily be interested in at
least seeing
it but there's a sense that because of
what they've done to
sideline economics in the immediate
context of burning man that they are
demonstrating about something about what
is
possible they're demonstrating something
about what is possible in a
habitat where nothing grows and
everything has been trucked in every
last thing that they are eating has been
trucked in and they are there for a
prescribed finite period of time and
they are all
wealthy this proves nothing about what
is possible in any context and the idea
that a bunch of people many of whom are
Tech utopians by their nature
look at this as if it has implications
about the way humans might get along if
only and the answer is no no that's
that's bad sci-fi there may be some good
art at Burning Man but what you're
learning about the way people interact
is bad sci-fi what you're what you're
doing only works for a brief period of
time it only works if you have a
bombproof birth control with a Sure Fire
backup program it only works if you've
got you know if you've planned carefully
and brought in enough food and even just
this recent one where you know what they
had was rain and
mud right it began to show how absurd
the belief structure that had grown up
around it
was um so anyway I do think people if
the power went off on planet Earth for a
week I don't know that we'd survive a
lot of lot of stuff would go wrong
including you know how many nuclear
reactors would the backup systems that
involve diesel fuel work hopefully all
of them but that's not guaranteed um but
uh anyway I do think people need a
wakeup
call that tells them just how far
they've gotten from knowing how to be a
human being without I don't think people
know how helpless they
are well I I too did not miss the irony
of this beautiful avanguard experiment
and what's possible for Humanity when it
comes together under the ages of a peace
and love Festival almost going Mad Max
because an inch of rain fell you know
uh yep yeah it got a little got a little
dicey there you know um but but this
this a larger it's a perfect
encapsulation metaphor for actually
where my work is which is around this
idea of saying look because I'm a
biologist by by training and and almost
all of my work in the lab was under
microscopes very high power differential
interference contrast microscopes which
allow to image living cells in very high
fidelity while they go about their
business you know and and um that's
where I
rediscovered uh a faith as it were it's
just it's it's so magnificently
complicated one cell looks like a city
from 10,000 feet with trucks and things
moving and it's just doing it's just
busy you know it's just astonishing
watching all of that um but as we come
into this next period of time
around uh biology at its core
all of every single you know this way
better T night every single organism
every moment of every day is primarily
concerned with where's my where's my
energy coming from right and we've
forgotten that thank you pe thank you
oil it was great we have this you know
several hundred year departure without
having to think too much about where our
next meal is coming from you know on on
balance right it it's it's historically
evolutionarily weird and so we've taken
that departure um and and you I'm going
to bet you look back going say well we
squandered that was awesome we could
have done some great stuff we could have
all become like you know enlightened
with that much free energy around
kicking around and we we chose to do
other things with it so given that but
this is my my larger framing
architecture which I know I'm early on
but I tried this on an audience the
other day it didn't go too far um uh but
but it goes like this we evolved to know
where our next meal is coming from no
different than when you know a herd of
wilderbeast see the grasses getting thin
by by whatever sensory apparatus they
have they wander off in search of new
grass right another Valley and so we
humans we don't have any more valleys to
go to we we've mapped it we we pretty
much know where every oil Basin is where
every air there's no surprise 60 million
square miles of of arable land that we
forgot about right we know we know what
we're up against and we're at 8 billion
people and we uh now at least 10 but
I've heard estimates as high as 20
calories out of every Food calorie that
I eat is just got fossil fuels embedded
in it right wait you said something that
can't be right 20 calories out of every
what every single calorie that lands on
my plate has up to 20 calories of fossil
fuel energy embedded in it fossil fuel
the return on investment has been one
Food calorie for 20 fossil fuel calories
loaded in up to about 1920 farming was
net positive which is how we built
civilizations it gave you a 10 10 to one
return the Farmer Plus a mule would put
out one calorie of energy but 10
calories of potatoes or wheat would come
back off of that um story we've been
upside down on that right we've been
we've been subsidizing our calorie
production right um to a huge extent
that's fine what's not fine is we don't
have a single plan anywhere I can
identify and I've been to every corner
that I can find where they've said oh
and here's how we're going to conduct
agriculture in the future when not if
but when this
this this source of fuel goes away right
Y and we don't just use oil to you know
do the run the tractors that's obvious
or make the pesticides that's obvious
but we you know use natural gas with the
habbos process to capture nitrogen which
is a triple bonded molecule out of the
atmosphere very stable does not like
being split asunder we use that energy
to give us free nitrogen um we use it to
transport to cool to ship to distribute
on and on
right to your point though back to you
know people may not that this may have
softened us up greatly I have a farm you
know Eevee and I we got cows we got
chickens Brett growing food takes a lot
of
work and I mean a
lot I'm embarrassed to say how much no I
look this is this is one of the places
where I know you took the right path and
I uh it's too late for me to take it but
uh you're what you're telling us about
farming is something that
um people do not understand they have a
a relationship with food that gets super
vague beyond the grocery
store they just don't get it and you
know the habbos thing ought to loom
large the idea that most of the
food most of the protein in
you actually comes from a process
derived from bomb making technology from
the first world war that allows us to
take nitrogen out of the atmosphere that
is not biologically available and make
it biologically available we have
radically transformed the Earth we have
changed the population of the Earth
radically by a chemical trick that takes
energy which we drive from fossil fuels
and turns it into
biology
and what you are saying and you said it
very clearly but I'm going to repeat it
because it's so
important it is one thing to do this
knowing that it cannot be sustained
forever if you know what you're going to
do when it stops being possible it is
another thing
entirely to do it knowing that it cannot
be
sustained and have no plan and assume
something will turn up because there is
absolutely no reason to think that
something will turn up and it could I
mean for me you talk about Zero Point
Energy I spent a lot of time thinking
about fusion fusion which has been 20
years away for the
last
60 as I count it right it's always just
Out Of Reach if we ever do get there and
I hope that we do um it liberates us all
these energy concerns potentially go
away although I will say to you what I
always say on this front which is that
if we discovered it tomorrow if we
discovered viable Fusion Energy
tomorrow without having set the
groundwork to keep the value of what we
have discovered so that it serves the
public I believe it would make things
worse and not better although it would
potentially solve a great many of the
problems that are existential threats
the economic
system would cause it to
become effectively weaponized against
the public and I think it would function
as an accelerant to many of the very bad
processes that threaten us but
nonetheless there are things out there
that could free us but the idea that
anybody is banking on the fact that
something's going to show up at the
right moment well what if it
doesn't right I I mean I I do want to
talk to you about peak oil which I know
you have um is a a drum you have been
beating for a long time and no doubt
changes in our energy environment have
probably caused you to rethink what you
once thought about peak oil um
but the overall picture can't be
terribly different there's still a
finite you know the Earth did not store
an infinite
quantity of hydrocarbons in the past
it's St a finite quantity and they have
gotten ever harder to reach and yes we
have liberated a bunch that weren't
available to us through Technologies
like fracking and deep ocean
drilling but um you know it's a fixed
quantity and even even if the answer is
yeah we're got to burn all that stuff um
there's a point at which there isn't
anymore or there's a point at which
the what remains is so expensive to
reach that there is effectively no
more there are some wonderful nuances to
this uh conversation and and potentially
the most important of them is this idea
of net energy right so um back in the
day spindle Top early turn of you know
the 1900s when people were finding this
they would find oil typically because it
was like literally bubbling out of the
ground Jed clampet style right they'd
like oh well let's drill here and
typically they would have to drill it
was a
nuisance yeah oil was a nuisance until
people figured out how to fractionate it
and utilize the components in various
different ways and the components are
you know things we're familiar with
kerosene for example is one of the
components asphalt is one of the
components so we've basically figured
out how to separate the goo into a bunch
of different useful things and you know
we pave roads with it and we fuel jets
with it and we fuel cars with it and
everything else um anyway didn't mean to
interrupt but yes it used to be was too
much of it it was annoying it was
annoying but it was easy it was
relatively easy to find that first stuff
I mean the first well in Titusville
Pennsylvania
1859 they drilled for it and the drill
rig was this sterk that could lift up a
large piece of of iron that was sort of
sharpish at the point and they would
just drop it right they would sort of
smash through the Shale layers until
they got down far enough that they could
I don't know what they did bucket the
stuff out because they didn't really
have pumps back then that that work that
way so so that was the first you know
they didn't even know what to do with it
when they had it you know and and then
an industry came up around it um but
even as recently as um you know the 40s
and 50s 60s we were still drilling down
like if you go to the gaar field it's in
Saudi Arabia this thing's a this is
massive 138 miles long 50 60 miles wide
it varies but depend you know on average
and it's down about 1100 feet that's
amazing they have wells that they put
down in the 40s that are still producing
3,000 barrels a day right one well 1,000
feet down all right but these were all
the oil this is what we call
conventional oil this is oil that was
trapped in in a pocket where where some
up folding it happened maybe it was a
salt Dome or it was a an anticline you
know some some geological formation but
it had a c Stone on it that was
impermeable because most of this oil was
formed in in a 400 to 100 million year
ago range for reasons um and and if you
had something that was even leaking one
drop per second you know just one drop
out of this you'd lose you know billion
Barrels in in that time frame they would
they would all be gone so it has to be
fairly
impermeable and but this is these were
these Pockets Brett where where the oil
had drifted up and the gas would go on
top and then there was you know the oil
and then water underneath just by by
density and so that's great so we found
most of those those ran out and and then
we started drilling this Shale oil which
is part two of the story but this is
what we call the parent rock right these
are flat Shale layers that had you know
people like oh is that dinosaurs like no
no it's algae you know because lipid B
layers all that you know it's that's
where the oil came from and then you
know now we're down in What's called the
parent rock and the mistake is to think
well you know we move from conventional
to Shale we'll just go to the next thing
there's no grandparent Rock in this
story right there's no there's nothing
deeper than that like this is it like
we're we're we're tapping this stuff
brilliant technology amazing people
doing it it's un but unbelievable what
they do but if you're in the bachan up
in North Dakota I went there and visited
one of these drill Rigs and and it's
just it's astonishing the power of what
they're doing but first they have to
drill down like 10,000 feet and then
they tip the drill bit sideways
beautiful technology and then they'll
drill sideways for up to another 10,000
ft right through a thickness of shale
that might be as deep as a two-story
house right to even find that do that
again brilliant right how they do that
and measure it and all that so and then
they do that and then they might do
these days up to a 100 100 stage Frack
right where they plug it and explode it
with this massive they have these chain
700 horsepower diesel um compressors
that are pushing down unbelievable
amounts of power down there and then
they explode it and move the toe and
explode it and move the toe 100 times
and then they get this well that might
start out at a th000 barrels a month but
typically it's you know um 800 um that
within three years is putting out maybe
20 barrels a day right so they have This
ferocious decline
rate right so it's not the same as
drilling down 1,000 feet and getting 40
50 60 years of 3,000 barrels a day these
things are pushing are you know you
drill it Frack it and the energy
required to do that just the energy
equation we're just doing an energy
budget how much energy does it take to
drill 10,000 another 10,000 Frack it
case it all that stuff and you might get
total 200 to 300,000 barrels out of that
well over its entire life start to
finish um it's a very different equation
so let me get back to net energy you and
I are talking and you and I have a
business and you and I lead our lives
and everybody listening to this leads
their lives because somebody
somewhere got energy for a net gain cuz
if was a one if they put one Barrel in
to get one barrel out there's no barrels
left for you and I to do what we're
doing right now yeah right so that
energy Surplus matters a lot and in the
story this is one of these nonlinear
stories so we used to get 100 to one and
then it was 50 to1 but when you track
out this curve of energy in energy out
it doesn't go down it goes along merily
till about 10 and then it
craters right if you if you plotted it
out because you know at 5 to1 we're
getting 50 out 50% you know I mean sorry
at one 1 to2 we get 50% out but at at 1
to three we get 30% out and on and on
but it it goes very it's an a it's a
very steep curve and we're already down
that curve a little bit right and by the
way fuel ethanol where we take the last
six inches of Midwest top soil to put in
our gas tanks that stuff has about a one
to 1.4 return You couldn't possibly run
a society on it yeah you know it's just
brain dead and that's the thing I'm
offended by is that is that this is
these are very easy
Concepts Shale oil there's only so many
drillable acres and we can see it and
we've got you know there's more there
don't get me wrong but we ought to be
having this conversation which says well
when we run out of drillable
Acres then what then what well okay so
this brings me to another uh quadrant
where I spent a lot of
time and it's gotten darker and darker
and darker the more I the more I
explore we are not having a conversation
that makes any sense with respect to to
Roi return on investment energy l or
return on energy investment roei is that
it yep
um why
not it's obvious right it takes you you
know you three paragraphs and you've
talked us into a state of knowledge in
which we could now intelligently discuss
the distinction between um ethanol and
uh frct Shale oil Etc where we are on
this curve and what it implies about our
future that's an intelligent
conversation not everybody be up to it
but enough people who would potentially
be able to then understand the world of
geopolitical forces and biological and
chemical and nuclear
opportunities we could have that
conversation and obviously we
should
however there is a process I keep
swearing that it's a bad name and that I
need to find a better one but people
keep telling me it's actually all right
time traveling money
printer time traveling money printer is
my placeholder name for the following
observation we all know how you make
money if you have a time
machine you can go forward in time and
find out what's going to happen and then
come back and bet on it or you can go
back in time and you can buy Apple
Microsoft Tesla whatever you can turn
small piles of money into huge piles of
money with a time machine but there are
no time
machines there are however things that
function like time machines you can do
the same trick by slowing the public
down in its awareness of what is taking
place so that you effectively have
information because people are
artificially foolish about what's going
on and the reason that I say this gets
very dark is that there comes a point at
which
you
realize that a general program of
bewildering the public of destroying the
mechanisms by which the public might
become
informed by sidelining the people who
are trying to tell it like it is putting
information into the public domain
destroying the universities where truth
seeking is supposed to be the core
Mission but it is now a social justice
Mission
um taking journalism and making sure
that everybody is living by the question
of which side their bread is buttered on
rather than a desire to win a prize by
unearthing a story that powerful people
didn't want
hold all of these
things leave us in the
public blind and the our blindness is
monetizable by anybody who doesn't
suffer from it to the extent that we are
slowed down in realizing what is taking
place other people will have placed bet
and they can transfer our wealth to them
in the market by knowing what historical
events are going to take place so what
I'm getting at is you can present in a
matter of three paragraphs a story on
which our future depends and we could at
least now have a conversation about what
rationally we should think about that
predicament this is not widely
understood not because it's difficult to
convey not because it isn't obvious how
important it is but because
because our
myopia is a source of wealth for others
we are being held in the state of what
economists might
call being greater
fools all right keeping people from
understanding what's going on turns them
into a source of wealth for people who
know more
and I don't know if I'm seeing a a if
that's just an accident that we're
becoming foolish and misinformed or if
our being foolish and misinformed is a
source of a different kind of energy for
a different class of people who
understands what they must do in order
to keep the spigot
flowing but um it is impressive how many
topics we are confused on
simultanously yeah well I would I would
submit that a warning sign that maybe
one of those um misinformation campaigns
is running is that the story lacks
coherence in some way you can you can
quickly judge that this is an incoherent
mess okay let me go to climate change
real quick I'm told in no uncertain
terms that this is the most powerful
most important thing I have jet setting
billionaires telling me all the time
that I need to take cold showers and and
travel less right um we have people
experimenting with 15minute cities and
floating the idea that maybe you should
only take one or two short Hall flights
per year and on and on and on right um
if this were true that they really cared
about this we would be seeing a
wholesale effort to rebuild our nuclear
industry in this country and there's no
effort whatsoever being undertaken right
we would see efforts to put like if you
fly into Israel or you fly into China a
lot of places you fly in you see solar
thermal collectors on the roof because
it turns out those are brilliant the sun
loves heating stuff up almost no magic
it's not very sexy it's box with pipes
in it in a single circulating pump it's
brilliant hot water represents 25% of
the use of energy in any given home
right so places that are sensible go
maybe we should do this right I can fly
into almost any City including in places
like Phoenix where it makes all the
sense in the world and see none of these
as we as we're coming in over the houses
as we're Landing right so there's total
incoherence in our story
about climate change which is
fundamentally incoherent in our story of
energy right I've read China's energy
policy they're not confused at all they
understand all of this intimately right
they have a beautiful five-point plan
they just unveiled this year it is
robust it understands the role of of
alternative energy and how it has to be
layered in slowly but that it's never
the center of the system because how
could it be given you know store
scalability and storability problems Etc
they understand that they have to make
nice with their neighbors so that it's a
win-win because they're going to have to
be importing da right they have
coherence in their Poli policy and
they're executing it it makes sense um
our policy is completely incoherent and
I think people make money because of
that incoherence they're going to make a
lot of
money so um I've been working
on some projects to surface some ways of
thinking to get around these
problems one of them
involves um getting people to an
awareness pie chart Arts are not
something that I saw very much in the
study of biology they're treated as uh
you know the stuff of business and uh
I'm not saying I never saw them but but
I think they're dramatically under
utilized when thinking about population
Dynamics and uh ways in which society
functions
because one pattern that we see again
and again
is people increasing the size of their
slice of the pie not by innovating which
is the cover story but by
destroying uh other slices of pie in
other words the overall volume of the
pie
shrinks but your slice gets bigger this
is something that
Society should Stamp Out by making it
unprofitable you should never make a
profit by destroying
wealth creating wealth is one thing
destroying wealth is another thing it's
a net loss even if you got a bigger boat
so what you're describing sounds to me
like a total failure of any patriotic
allegiance to the population we still
have flag waving and the pretense that
there's a nation but what we also have
as people in a position
to slow us down in our awareness of
things who are destroying our future and
getting rich in the process and
presumably they will not go down with
the
ship
so that's a critical problem a failure
of patriotism is really in some sense
the issue there you wouldn't do that to
a nation that you cared about you
wouldn't do it to a population that you
felt was an extension of you but you
would cynically do it to people who
meant nothing to you and we see an awful
lot of behavior that is best explained
by that exact failure
so
um and your your point about China is
perfect it'd be bad enough if you did
that to your population in the absence
of a major competitor who was doing
precisely the opposite but
effectively you are handing us over
you are subjecting future Generations
from the West to
values that are currently on display in
China that we should want no part
of and
[Music]
um I don't know how we call people's
attention to this fact
but the uh I think the core message here
is you and I are both practitioners of
what I would call First principles
thinking first principles thinking is
almost the only thing that still works
in an era where you're being fed garbage
and the authorities are all at least
tied up in a system that has them
confused if not outright on the
take first principle thinking is how you
bootstrap an understanding of a system
without reliable anything you just
simply compare you figure out what might
actually be a fact you compare those
facts to each other and you say what
what ways might they actually fit the
same story and what happens to people
like you and me is our [__]
detectors are constantly going off
because we're constantly be being given
Stories the purpose of which is not to
inform us so that then causes us to say
hey wait a minute and to try to educate
other people because we are public
spirited and that also makes
us I don't know how seriously they take
us but it it makes makes us enemies of
the powers that are profiting through
these mechanisms so we are derided as
conspiracy theorists or whatever the
stigma of the hour
is and the question is what to do about
it really what we need is more people to
say actually you know what I sure wish I
had followed the first principles
thinkers through Co because they did
much less harm to
themselves I just know that if I look
back on the people who were doing this
particular trick those people spotted
bad thinking earlier and ended up
healthier same thing with the story
unfolding in the Middle East same thing
with all of these stories it's not the
first principles thinking done by lone
individuals isolated
except by virtue of a polluted internet
through which we interact um it's that
there really is nothing else you know
there is no journalism somehow amazing
is that statement sounds there is no
University system there is no
institutional structure doing this job
and so all we've got are people who
somehow bootstrapped this capacity in
isolation and insist on continuing to do
it I I I agree and and let me try a
hypothesis out um it goes like this um
humans have always been about power and
control and Once Upon a Time you exerted
that by having slaves or Andor surfs
right but oh my God what a pain right
you have to feed them you have to clothe
them they're trying to run away they do
uprisings you got medical costs it's a
pain um and then we stumbled across this
great idea of fractional Reserve banking
you know which is awesome because I put
Brett into debt and now he's my [__]
you know he does whatever I need him to
do right and and you will self-own
yourself you'll you'll be you'll you
know you will be in your own prison
going well I took on this debt and I'm
going to lose my house or my boat if I
don't you know so you work really hard
it's it's just when you strip it away
it's really just a better form of
slavery right because the slaves own
themselves it's great it's a great model
the keepers of the system manufacture
the money out of thin air right and you
it's it's very different thing in your
life in my life it's a tangible thing
where things get hard when you run out
of it right if not desperate so we have
that I think what we're seeing now is
this switch to a third order arrangement
where actually the power is in the
cognition itself and in narrative
control so it's even better BR if I can
be controlled by somebody who can
control how I think and what I think so
freedom of speech means nothing to me if
I don't have freedom of thought I see
people now who who have lost the ability
of freedom of thought because the the
the the control systems are really good
so this to me I think n information is
the new Power it's the new Battlefield
you and I fight this all the time I'm
just every day now I'm like how many of
these things on Twitter are just Bots
how many of them are government Bots how
many of them are public private NGO
partnership Bots I don't know right but
it's a lot of many of them I just want
to put on the radar of people because I
think it's looming very very large many
of them are organized armies of paid
trolls and when we say bot it calls up
the wrong thing because a bot is
inherently stupid a person who is paid
to create a particular impression
especially if they are doing so in
conjunction with 20 other people people
who've been assigned a task is a very
powerful thing because what it does is
it uses the human API expertly that is
to say we all have a sense of what it
means when a person says something
hostile or challenging to us we react
like human beings do and when the thing
that you're interacting with is one of
20 representatives of an organization
whose name you do not know that has
identified your account and says it is
time to create the the following
impression around Chris Martinson right
that is a very powerful force it is a
force capable of um preventing a an
awareness that would otherwise Dawn from
occurring so anyway sock puppets and you
would go ahead you you would agree
though that that level of narrative
control has gotten all the way down to
the individual
level what do you mean like people
you're targeted I'm targeted like like
like like there's enough force behind
this now that they're not just arguing
in the comment section under the New
York Times to shape a a you know an
appearance of of Conformity no there is
a project with your name on it and the
status of that project and the
institutional knowledge of that project
what are your blind spots what are your
uh
sensitivities what are the Impressions
that can be created around your feed
that will cause people who might
otherwise listen to you to turn away and
walk the other direction these things
are somehow being wielded in a
sophisticated way but I will say before
I return you to wherever you were headed
uhuh the
power of whatever is doing this and you
know with coid we learned the names of
many of these organizations you know the
trusted news initiative the gab Alliance
um all of these various components of
the Weaponry um became visible over time
who knows how many we haven't seen yet
but there are you know a dozen
organizations that set about to various
pieces of controlling the narrative
spectacular how ineffective they were
now I'm not saying they didn't I can't
speak for you they uh put a lot of dents
in my ship that's for sure right the the
difference between the trajectory that I
was on before coid and the trajectory
following it was uh profound but the
degree to which these [__]
lost right 2% of people are getting
these boosters so yeah we took a lot of
hits and it was very unpleasant and it
has meaningful consequences and I really
want people to think about what that
means that they are capable of
disrupting the lives of those who are
trying to tell you the truth right in
the most profound ways
but
as ferocious as the force that we have
faced
is they are losing they are losing
control of the narrative and I'm worried
that what they do next is stop dealing
with this at the level of narrative
control or at least dealing with it at
the level of persuasion and nudging and
all of that that they they uh they're
not good people they obviously don't
care about um anyone but themselves and
that means that the options on the table
for them are presumably many I mean they
you know they obviously were perfectly
comfortable uh giving people an
absolutely insane new technology that uh
maimed many and killed quite a number so
I I don't think I don't think they give
a damn about uh ending people so I worry
about that um but anyway you were
talking about the uh the massive
investment that is put into controlling
the discussion online through various
mechanisms sock puppets yeah Bots y all
that stuff so so the hypothesis rests on
that observation which is that they
whoever they are whatever the system is
cares enough about narrative shaping and
control that it's gotten all the way
down to the atomic level you and me
right it's it's like it's like all the
way down right so so the control freaks
fine um and so the then we say well if
if it's gotten to the individual level
it's not Unthinkable we know from the
Snowden releases in 2015 that they were
already operating at the a sophisticated
bot level with just actual software
programming um under the comment
sections of all the major newspapers so
if an article came out about the Federal
Reserve or something you know they had
to shape the appearance that this is
what people think right so they were
doing that that's a long time ago in
technology speak um my my my position is
this this narrative control of course
they're not going to leave something as
important as our most critical signaling
devices to their own devices cuz why
that would be terrible if people
actually got real information think what
they might do right the most important
signaling device we have right now are
financial markets and they are I have
all the data I've got this wonky stuff I
can show you how they do it it's like
get all this and that but they've been
controlling okay so fine they like
stocks to go up into the right they like
they they like to set the price of money
they do all this here's the
problem when you're shaping a narrative
by definition you're picking an outcome
that you already think you know so you
you're smarter than everybody else
you're smarter than the collective
wisdom of the markets and you know what
the right price for something should be
they've been doing this with oil now for
a number of years I thought the oil
markets were larger than them but it
it's not true so we saw obviously Biden
dump the spr to try and drive the price
of oil down and he did but I can show
you the financial tracks of how somebody
would come in and dump 20 million
barrels of oil in a one minute window
and it would crush the bid stack and
create a lower price for oil and then
they would manage that so while they're
doing that that's fine they had reasons
they needed you know it would be
unfortunate if the Ukraine conflict said
to people that because of that your
gasoline's going to be more expensive it
would be unfortunate you know it's
always a bad time to have reality
intrude in the narrative right but this
became systematized over many decades
and now it's just a matter of routine
and they do it here's my concern while
they were keeping oil held down for the
past years it hasn't been at a level
sufficient to justify offshore drilling
which is the nuclear Basel load of oil
production trillions of dollars has not
been invested over the past seven years
and if we suddenly wake up one day and
said we need more oil you don't just
flick a switch and throw a trillion in
the the materials might not be there the
labor might not be there the leases have
to be negotiated it's complicated these
are Big this is like oil offshore oil is
like a farmer who plants a seed that
matures in seven years right there's a
big latency lag in this story right um
but meanwhile The Narrative keepers have
been have in service of the narrative
they've done some things that now are
gonna I guarantee you are going to
shoehorn us into a very uncomfortable
situation in the future um because the
investment simply hasn't been there and
so this is my my biggest concern is that
our markets have become
fictionalized they're mainly a conduit
for transferring wealth from the many to
the few the few happen to be big names
you know Ray doll IO Ken Griffith I'm
sure they're very smart guys but none of
them produce anything none of them made
a single widget pair of underwear none
of them grew a single fig nothing the
skimmers you know have have sort of like
are the system now and it it's a it's a
funky little environment but the the
fact that we have this inability to have
the market set the prices for things
means we're not getting the right
information so this is fundamentally an
an information Fidelity problem we now
have more signal than less signal than
noise and this is going to really hurt
us yeah it is and I you know I cannot
help but wonder whether the rent seeking
Elites that are driving this
system are as dumb as they
appear they
are
creating Chaos on a planet they cannot
leave and
and the there are a number of ways that
that could play out and I I'll I'll put
two on the table and uh we can talk
about what you
see one there's a a a thread I call it
the collapse game and the idea is I
heard somebody say recently
um we're not all in the same boat we're
all in the same storm
some of us are in rowboats some of us
are in battleships the storm affects us
differently but we're all in the same
storm but my concern
is evolutionarily historically over the
span of history and
prehistory
Elites have faced the
following
truth which is collapse hurts
everybody but it often hurts your
competitors more than it hurts you and
so it can be that positive if collapse
destroys your competitors and hurts you
but you
inherit what your competitors had by
virtue of it you know cleaning out the
environment if that's true in a general
sense it would cause people to detect
when they are in that Elite spot hey I'm
better position than anybody else to
deal with a collapse and it would cause
the elites who feel that they are in
this position to
become Reckless with respect to the
things that would cause it because the
basic point is actually it's kind of a
feature not a
bug and in the
present that doesn't work because the
Technologies on which we all depend and
the interrelatedness of everything and
the Weaponry available to us all of the
things that are in Play Now function at
a scale that takes what used to be true
which is that collapse could serve those
best position to withstand it and means
that maybe none of us withstand it but
you wouldn't expect the understanding of
that it would be a much more visceral
willingness to gamble amongst people who
were well positioned that might get us
all into a situation we simply can't get
out
of right that's one possibility is that
we're B we're being it's a Ship of Fools
and those fools are operating on
out-of-date information about
where uh where there is a future and
where there is
not other possibility is that
um they have understood exactly where
they are
and that the story you tell only plays
out the way you say it does uh if our
energy demands remain the same and that
a lot of the weird you know failure to
give a [__] that they're
killing people through bad
Pharma the uh deafness to
um the
various there's an awful lot of thinking
that says the population needs to be
lower and we can argue about that um I
know you and I
probably uh while we detest the people
saying these things
and find their logic feeble also
recognize that the habbos processes
jacked the population up with no Exit
Plan and so while
um it isn't clear what's supposed to
happen My Hope Is that uh we get really
wise really fast discover Fusion uh
apply it correctly um and we make a
sustainable Planet uh and you know pick
a population level that can be
maintained with everybody being free and
well taken care of but I also think
that's unlikely so there's a question
about whether or not the people who have
these discussions and used to talk about
um population have taken those plans to
some other level that they're not
sharing and you know is that just a
Wildey
conspiracy uh Theory or is there
something to the idea that somebody is
actually looking to address the problem
by reducing the amount of energy we need
um by allowing the population to drop in
some
way well the depopulation thing comes up
a lot and I
can't um I have a hard time dismissing
it out of hand breath because uh there's
a lot of statements and like as I said
we go back to the WF crowd and we're
using them as a placeholder for these
Elites and I believe that they're just
the frontmen for this organization I
think the truly truly Elite people never
show up on the Forbes 400 list right you
know it's just that's that's go that's
that's n
right that's a rookie move rookie yeah
that that's like a SE first second
generation kind of a thing wait you've
been around 10 Generations you know then
you'll get it you'll work this right so
then you'll know um but you know again
back to that the the WF putting out that
idea that by 2050 we need two and a half
planets well we don't have two and a
half planets so we have one right and
then let's imagine as well that they
have access to the same data I have
maybe better probably better they
actually know how much Saudi Arabia has
or doesn't have left in its oil reserves
they know and you this is just a simple
calculation you go okay how does this
work now this is my my seminal theory
that I I not the my the way I look at
the world is that we have an exponential
money system it works really well when
it's growing exponentially it's great
you know it doesn't go in reverse at all
it hates reverse it just doesn't know
how to manage reverse right so uh as
long as our credit in the system is
expanding by some percentage 8 n% a year
it's reasonably happy um the problem is
is that our income has been growing at
less than half that rate and these two
things are compounding against each
other you know away from each other and
we're at that asymptotic phase like like
this this like uh oh we're going like
this we're going like this before we
don't know what it's going to happen
when it levels out but this is where we
are in it's really easy to reason
through so they talk about a great reset
our monetary system is in the final
throws of trying to desperately ignore
something which is completely obvious
which is that we've made way too many
claims on the future that can't be met
right so so when people ask me Chris
summarize all your financial theories in
one one sentence I'll say great it's
very simple all we have to resolve is
who's going to eat the
losses and now we can put the players on
the table the bankers always like it not
to be them they've been very successful
at getting bailed out you know taking
the obscene profits during the fat years
and getting bailouts during the the UN
unfat years right the politicians don't
want it to be them right and everybody's
going to hope that the the little people
will be the patsies for this again right
as we always are we are Charlie Brown
and they they are Lucy holding the
football Time After Time the problem has
been that this thing called the internet
came along Brett and people are on to
the scams now yeah and so their job has
to be fracturing us and keeping us away
from each other so we can't organize
into a a coalition that says wait a
minute we'd like to have a seat at this
table when we answer the question who's
going to eat the
losses I think that explains a lot of
what we're seeing yeah it unfortunately
does and we can rephrase some of what
you've said in some very ugly ways that
will rescue what I've said very clumsily
here there's a lot
of food produced in this system to feed
us if a massive contraction is coming
that food can be reapportioned and the
people who are going to get it are the
people with the power whoever they might
be so in other words it is a little bit
like a version of living on a feed lot
but not understanding that you're
not you know in the Garden of
Eden um your resources will feed them if
lean times
come
uh
two other things you talk about growth
versus going in reverse so uh I've
been hammering this particular note um
it's a long-standing thread for me but
I've been talking about it in public in
light of the the crisis in the Middle
East because I think it is the
perspective which allows us to
understand what's actually in
Play We Are in a battle between what I
call the West which is not a geographic
description of anything it is a set of
values and a way of organizing a
civilization that is superior to the
ancestral way it is Superior in that it
is fairer it is safer it is less violent
it is more productive it is more
liberating it is more rewarding it is
better in every
way the one way in which we cannot make
that argument is that it is fragile it
only works this version of the West only
works under positive sum Dynamics as the
pi is expanding works great because it
doesn't make sense to bludgeon your
neighbor and steal from them when there
is wealth to be produced by
collaborating with your neighbor so we
tend to do a good job of putting race
aside for example and collaborating
based on opportunity undergrowth
circumstances when you reverse the
polarity and things contract fact what
we do is we the system the West breaks
down into the ancestral system which I
call lineage displacement games and the
idea is blood is thicker than water
becomes the dominant Arbiter of who you
collaborate with and we get very ugly
tragedies of history as people get rid
of other people and take their stuff so
that is the predicament and my refrain
is we have no choice going forward the
only way a planet this Hightech
integrated and
well-armed can continue is if we
stabilize the conditions that allow the
West to flourish and globalize so that
everybody gets to participate in that
system that's really the question we
either do that or I believe we will face
one ugly end or another as a
species okay in that
light you have this question you say the
internet comes along people are no
longer falling for the scams because we
can now compare notes and do things like
that this is absolutely right I believe
that the reason that as powerful as the
elites are that they fumbled the ball on
Co is that they really didn't know what
a podcast was or why it should matter
and they thought okay we own all the
major properties we'll just control the
story that didn't work why didn't that
work um because there's something called
a podcast and people can talk and it's
clumsy and the production value are low
but you know it's amazing what they do
oh well then we'll just we'll hey let's
get the New York Times a podcast
everybody will listen to that one
because it's better really no not true
they're gonna listen to Joe Rogan weird
as that sounds yeah the fighter so
anyway that thing upended them
and there's only so long they're going
to put up with this this is what all the
Draconian [__] is about misce and
Mal information we have now as of
yesterday seen Israel making noises
about uh locking people up who say
things that cause a drop in morale Etc
the same [__] is unfolding as it
always will but we also
see something that for the moment I'm
calling the Coalition slicer dicer
effect where we you know we had an
amazing very painfully constructed
Coalition of coid dissidents people with
a wide range of expertise from
vaccinology to toxicology to
evolutionary biology to several
different Stripes of medicine right all
of those things existed in the Coalition
and that Coalition was in a great
position of statisticians we had a lot
of different skills and that Coalition
was in a great position to actually
check the work of the official narrative
which was like laugh ably bad when you
scrutinized
it which is why only 2% of people are
getting boosters now because we broke
their
narrative oh bad news the conflict in
the Middle East just so happens to land
a direct hit on that Coalition so now we
can't even talk to each other anymore
right people have divided on a false
dichotomy and they view each other with
suspicion now maybe that's just an
accident but the point is
this is now happening repeatedly where
the churning of what Mark Andre calls
the next big thing where there's some
big thing you know I don't know what
happened to Ukraine I was told I needed
to focus all my energy on it you know
three weeks ago um and now I don't hear
it mentioned um because we're on to the
next big thing the churning of this next
big thing machine causes any Coalition
that develops any capacity to
basically function like a Grassroots
institution relative to some topic get
slammed with a dividing force and can't
play the next round of the
game now I think we need to get wise to
this and we need to start realizing that
the only people who are
really who really belong in the
discussion are people who are playing by
The Meta rules that will allow them to
address anything that comes up with
rigor and decency and an explicit and
carefully chosen set of values it's not
about the particular thing and hey I
noticed you're failing to wave the
correct flag this week Chris because
that mean you're morally defective right
that thing cannot be allowed to take the
Grassroots institutions that are
actually springing up and demonstrating
capacity to be destroyed on the regular
by something that just simply cannot
afford to have them
around well I I agree I I don't I don't
do Left Right politics I don't do this
flag that flag stuff you know I got in
trouble a lot with you know such as it
is I get in trouble with everything
because people like oh you know you are
you pro- Russia or you know Pro Ukraine
I'm like well I'm neither my my
understanding of that conflict starts in
2013 when I first wrote about the the
the dissolution of the European
Association agreement and yanukovich
chose not to do that and then there was
this mysterious color Revolution and
then McCain showed up with Victoria
newand by you know 2014 and and the rest
you know and then since then they've
killed 10,000 people plus shelling
across into the donbass regions and then
finally you know here we are like
there's this context it just it it you
know it's I I watch this thing people
just show up like like this thing with
Hamas just it just came out of nowhere
has no context it just happened and it's
awful and I agree it was completely
awful I think that um there's just no
excuse anybody does anything like that
to anybody I love and care about I get
it I'm right there for the blood
Vengeance but it didn't just happen out
of nothing you know and so that's the
thing I hate is they always present
these things as if you know are you
prask or anti-mask are you Pro vaccine
or antivaccine and our side is like I
think there's Nuance here right wait a
second wait a second sorry I don't want
I don't want to uh screw up your role
keep going
well I I you know to me it's not left
right anymore up down right and so what
is that up down axis for me that axis
has always been integrity versus
rigidity um you know ideological
rigidity so what do I mean Integrity to
me what there are a lot of definitions
but to me the the definition that
resonates for me the most is that you
have high integrity when you stand ready
to be completely re-educated at any
moment in
time yes um my friend alexandros marinos
uh has been banging the drum of
epistemic
humility which I think is synonymous
with what you are describing it is a
willingness to accept that your
understanding is imperfect and that
means you may have to swallow a reversal
of any size based on new information and
if you can't do that and if you don't
behave like your highest objective is to
figure out what's actually going on um
then you're not really playing the same
game well I mean a lot of people think
integrity means you know I've got the
Integrity of an oak like I'm I'm
unchanging right it's not that it's that
I am strong enough in myself that I'm
not attached to the ideas right I've
mentioned that before that I have to
work hard at that because my ego can get
attached to things but so I I work at
this but but to be completely
re-educated like if somebody came along
and said Chris I need a half hour I've
got all the data there really is a flat
Earth and let me show you and they can
prove this to me I'm going to have to go
okay wow I had that wrong I'm going to
have have my own cartisian crisis you
know now now where do I go but but I I
do believe that that um that's that's
what they're trying to forall they don't
want critical thinking they don't want
you to think for yourself they want to
just push you into this thing right and
and so there's a lot of those
dichotomies and they're all false
they're all traps democrat or republican
well there's a un a party
actually you know um for what it's worth
I maintain a list of things it's not
complete who knows what emerge but I
maintain a list of things that if I
encountered them in a compelling form
where I actually believed that the
evidence was what it looked like I would
have to reverse my position on darwinian
Evolution as the explanation for uh the
diversity of life on Earth and I don't
expect ever to see these things I am a
spent my life thinking about Evolution
I'm a DieHard believer I could recite to
uh you know an unending stream of
evidence that points in that direction
but it doesn't mean that there aren't
things that if I saw them like you know
a Bible verse of a particular length um
in inscribed in the Genome of some
creature that nobody had had the
opportunity to mess with you know that
it wouldn't force me to think about it
if aliens stepped off a spacecraft from
a foreign body and spoke English right
that would cause me to have to rethink
because there's stuff right there
there's a list of things that would
sufficiently uh that would tell me yep
you've wasted your life uh your life's
work is wrong and it is time to start
with a fresh sheet of paper so that that
is in some sense something we all have
to do what would really tell you that
you had gotten even the most fundamental
stuff you believe wrong including things
like the roundness of the Earth but I
wanted to go back to your excellent
point about the false dichotomies that
these false dichotomies are traps and
this
couldn't possibly be more important the
way the story the next big thing will
come at you it will come at you in the
form of a choice between two things and
your gut will tell you the answer is
that one right I just watched Ukraine
invaded by Vladimir Putin a murderous
Maniac has invaded a sovereign country
right it is time for me to put the
Ukrainian flag in my bio right perfectly
straightforward why you would conclude
that makes moral
sense but it
misses a whole layer of
nuance that causes the story to be one
in which maybe that's the right answer
but not for a straightforward reason I'm
not arguing that I'm not on the side of
Ukraine against Russia but I am also not
on the side of anything that would have
lured or forced that to unfold for
reasons that I'm not in on right why did
NATO cause conditions that would make
Russia feel uh vulnerable that would
induce it to do this if I'm against the
invasion of Ukraine I'm against anything
that would put Ukraine in Jeopardy of an
Invasion From
Russia I'm
definitely against barisma energy I
don't know what it is but I do know that
it's been corrupting my country and that
it's an energy outfit and that it hires
people who don't know [__] because of
their connection with powerful corrupt
Elites so which flag do I put in my bio
that says I stand with the people who
are against bisma in Ukraine that's not
it doesn't have a flag right it needs a
flag but it doesn't have one
so I think the the Chris Marson rule
here is the dichotomy the false
dichotomy if you can spot a dichotomy
that you're being asked to declare sides
on on the Bas of some basis of some uh
moral precept and you can spot that
there is Nuance that would force you to
want to embrace something for which
neither side
speaks then it's a
trap and the thing then goes into
another mode right so it says well which
side are you on are you on Putin's side
or are you on the side of the Ukrainian
people who have just been attacked by
this demon right well I'm on the side of
the Ukrainian people and that means I'm
against bisma energy and I don't know
what flag I'm supposed to be waving
right the burisma energy had it it
somehow put the people of Ukraine in
danger and I am on their side
so what am I supposed to do when you get
to that level then the point is the
thing comes after you the machine that
you described that has Bots and sock
puppets and organized armies of trolls
who create a phony conversation in your
replies or whatever the thing is comes
after you and it tries to turn the heat
up on the area where the truth actually
is somewhere not exactly in either of
the camps that you've been told you have
to join and by driving the heat up most
people will Retreat they'll they don't
know what just hit them they think God
I'm being I'm being morally questioned
because I haven't put the Ukraine flag
in my bio yet so maybe I'll just do that
because at least I'm on the side of the
people of Ukraine right anyway that
process is one we have to wise up and
learn to
spot every time it's a trap every time
there's some
third position that hasn't been
articulated and somebody is going to
struggle mightily to prevent it from
being articulated and it's kind of our
job to figure out what it is each and
every
time I completely agree and and this
gets me to
um I think what the thing I as I get
older Brett the thing I'm coming to is
that I'm starting to see the great
tragedy of of that right which you know
HL minin said that the point of politics
is to present people with a never-ending
series of hop goblins you know um and
and so now they've really ramped that up
the next current thing right and you see
people it's it's black lives matters
it's it's the shot it's flag this flag
not that flag this flag forget that
that's last week and it's just this
never ending thing so what's the tragedy
in that the tragedy is that those things
push us down if you know maso's
hierarchy of needs has been very useful
to me because you know if you have the
physiological needs if you can breathe
and excrete then you can get to Safety
and Security and then you can actually
have sense of belonging and you know by
the time you get to the top it's true
self-actualization existentially I think
that's why we're here that's why I think
I'm here so to the extent I can derive
meaning and purpose out of of my life
War gives people a sense of meaning and
purpose that's one level but I would
submit to you it's not a a very
growthful level there's not a lot of
additional Le lessons to be gleaned
there on a sole Journey basis but but
you know why are you here why is anybody
here I submit you can't answer that
question in the cacophony of noise of
being constantly stimulated into some
new fear response State because that's
the habituated state we're in fear
response fear response fear response and
some people have gotten quite adct to it
and they love it and if everything
magically went away they would I think
you'd find people clamoring for more of
it it's a tragedy though CU because
that's not why we're here right and and
to the extent that we're we're problem
defining the solution space for me has
got to be look for from an evolutionary
standpoint if we humans are going to be
around in a 10 million years or a
million years or 10,000 years if we're
going to do that I submit to you we're
going to have to break out of these old
metaphor narrative patterns and find
some new ones right and so how do you do
that how do you move towards that new
state and I I'm convinced that all of
this noise that you and I sort of battle
on a daily basis is is designed to keep
us off of that question um and that
that's that's the actual job right now
is how to I'm old enough I've I you know
I'm I'm the pound puppy that's going to
be scared of brooms for the rest of its
life for reasons we we don't know right
it's just something in my background
that's me I am what I am old dog but I I
believe that I can help create a
container where these where young people
can come in and actually begin to evolve
in in new ways right and I'm deeply
disappointed to see that the people who
we've entrusted with that sacred Duty
universities right um and other sort of
you know teachers in their lives have
completely [__] that
up so taught them how not to think
they've they've broken critical thinking
they've broken their Spirit to be to
actually dare to be re-educated it's
it's it's the most bizarre thing to me
yes they they have it I mean as with so
many things in very recent history the
thing has become its
inverse right I I have two College age
Sons but I'm not really rooting for them
to go to college because as much as
college is presumably still a place that
serves certain functions like
integrating you with members of your
generation so that you can figure out
how to set your adult life off in the
right direction I don't
know it is obviously a place in which
you are going to have to actively work
not to become
stupider like I really believe that if
they're going to if you're going to come
into a biology class and they're going
to tell you that sex is a spectrum or
you're going to go into a math class and
they're going to tell you that two plus
to can equal four but not
inherently right or they're going to
tell you that actually you know it used
to be that we discriminated against
pedophiles but now we understand that
they are minor attracted
persons if they're going to tell you any
of this [__] they are working to unhook
Your Capacity to think well enough to
even act in your own interest and I
don't want to send my kid
somebody I deeply love and have
invested two decades into bringing to
the brink of their adult life I don't
want to send them to a re-education camp
that makes you
stupid that seems like a dumb move on my
part so anyway we are there um and again
I
think just as no institutions function
but we are learning to bootstrap things
Grassroots institutions outside of the
institutions that do this is the same
question you need to be educated it
doesn't stop when you graduate from high
school but what then what is a real
education at this point that's that's
the
question I had one other thing I wanted
to say sorry I keep doing that to you I
keep putting two things on the table at
once and it's really bad form but in
response to your last point
the the word that we need to focus on is
counterintuitive in the circumstance
where you are being presented a false
dichotomy in the circumstance where you
are facing the same puzzle that Humanity
has faced for centuries and you're about
to do it again and you know that it's a
cycle that doesn't go anywhere good and
is only getting more dangerous based on
new weapons the answer is you can be
certain that the right move is going to
involve a healthy dose of the
counterintuitive you're going to have to
think some thought that sounds wrong at
first you're going to have to make some
move that people are going to swear is
immoral or unbearably dangerous or
something you're going to have to do
something unexpected to break out of the
trajectory which you know in the end
leads nowhere and so I would just say
people need to look at that and they
need to
budget oh I'm going to have to say
something that's going to get me in
trouble I don't know which thing it is
yet but there's no way out of this
puzzle that doesn't have me saying
something that's going to cause people
to swear I'm a bad
guy okay maybe I'll just budget for that
all right there's going to be something
counterintuitive and people are going to
have a hard time with it at first so
that's just where I am until further
notice yeah uh the way I think about
that is um Charles eisenstein framed
this really brilliantly he's such a
beautiful writer but he called this this
is the interregnum right we're between
stories right and so the old narrative
is infinite growth and you know the bank
we this is how banking operates this is
what geopolitics means and all that
developed and made a lot of sense like
I'm old I can't even believe I can say
this but when I was born 1962 there were
three billion people on the planet right
in a year or two there might be 9
billion who else has been alive when 6
billion new Souls have come on this
planet I mean it's it's like a whole
like I don't even know how we adapt to
to that level of change so so but that
old story of we don't really have to do
energy budgeting because there's always
more and we'll think of something and we
can just you know treat nature as the
Disposable repository for whatever waste
streams or you know soil every ton of
food we grow loses six tons of top soil
right now under current practices so we
all like we can squint at that and say
that doesn't seem sustainable whatever
so that's the old story but we don't
know what the new story is yet and
that's like the king is dead but we
don't know which of the uncles and Sons
is going to actually Seize the Throne so
we don't know which regime we're going
to be living under in the interregnum is
a highly destabilizing uncomfortable
place to be and that's where we are
we're in that interregnum between
stories and so that's both frightening
but the exciting part is well guess what
there's a lot of Leverage people who
actively rewrite the new stories like
you said say that wrong thing um you
know dare to say something that will
offend people that's how new stories get
written right so this is an incredible
moment of time where good thinking
people hopefully come together and
people of of good faith come together
and figure out if this is a time when
stories get Rewritten I'd like a hand in
that I would I would like to have a seat
at that table I would like to have some
input um I I fully agree with this and
unfortunately it puts me in the mind of
a uh a scene
in The Hitchhiker Guide to the
Galaxy um which haunts always good to
bring that up yeah it's it's a great one
it's a it's you know how how true
Brilliance is conveyed in the form of a
an excellent story and um just
unbearably powerful
humor um but there's a piece of the
story that haunts me um and it will
probably sound arrogant for me to
describe it but I'm going to do it
anyway cuz it's later than we
think you'll remember that in The
Hitchhiker's
Guide the Earth is actually a
sophisticated computer designed to
discover the meaning of life the
universe and everything after the
initial computer that was designed to do
this after I think thousands of years
spit out an insane answer which was 42
which didn't mean anything and then when
asked to explain it it said what was the
question so the Earth was the 2.0
version of the investigator for what is
the meaning of life the universe and
everything and as you will recall the
computer actually
produced its
result the Earth did figure out what the
meaning of life the universe and
everything was in the form of a young
woman on whom it
dawned and she picked up the phone to
convey the answer at the exact moment
that the vogans destroyed the
place they to put a throughway right
right space bypass that had been on file
in the whatever Planet held the uh
paperwork and it's your own damn fault
for not complaining when you had a
chance um so anyway the point is the
earth spits out the answer but we still
don't know what it is because lo and
behold it was destroyed at exactly the
moment that the answer was ready to be
delivered
um I feel a little bit like I might be
the young woman in that story because I
believe that actually evolutionarily I
do know what the next thing is supposed
to be
and it isn't that
complex and
it's
um we describe it Heather and I in our
book in the last chapter it's called the
fourth
Frontier and actually it's worth talking
about what the first three Frontiers are
so you see why there needs to be a
fourth and actually you hinted it this
earlier in our
conversation human beings like all
creatures seek Frontiers Frontiers are
untapped opportunities either an
opportunity that isn't being competed
for by any other entity or one that is
being underutilized something that you
can make evolutionary well-being being
out of so we seek Geographic
Frontiers where there are no other
people you might find an island or a
continent on which there are no people
but the stuff of Life exists and you
might instead of producing two surviving
Offspring which is the expectation in a
population that is not
growing you might produce thousands of
surviving Offspring beating the odds
tremendously that's a geographic
Frontier and there have been many but as
you point out we're done finding them
we've found everywhere there is on this
planet and the next planet isn't any
good and our ability to utilize it is a
long way off in time so Geographic
Frontiers are done then you have
technological Frontiers these are places
where you learn how to do more with what
you already have so the move from
hunting and Gathering to farming
obviously allows a population to grow as
if it has found a new habitat even
though it hasn't just making more of
what it's got and that can be true you
know crop rotation habbos process
anything that allows you to put more
people on the same plot of land
constitutes a
technological Frontier and so the point
is evolution has turned us into growth
addicts because growth addicts always
find the opportunity to make more wealth
and therefore allow the population to
grow and because that's evolutionarily a
win we are obsessed with finding those
opportunities we look for growth all the
time and we're very good at it which is
why we're so ingenious at creating new
ways of doing uh what um what
Buckminster Fuller called
ephemeralization which he defined as the
tendency to make more and more with less
and less until eventually you can make
everything with
nothing um so anyway those are the first
two Frontiers the third Frontier isn't a
real Frontier when the growth runs out
when you don't have a new technological
innovation that allows you to have more
abundance than you have
need people start looking at other
populations of people people with wealth
who can't defend themselves who their
wealth can be captured and it means this
is again back to pie charts my
population's pie can grow if I can find
a population that can't defend its slice
of pie and get rid of them and take
their
stuff this is the tragedies history all
right this is the Holocaust this is a
population faced with an economic
contraction that decides hey we need
some growth we don't have a mechanism
for growth but if we go after the Jews
then the good times will be back and so
they come up with an excuse and they go
after the Jews and the point is that's
that's what history looks like in the
lineage displacement regime that
dominates when uh we are in zero sum or
negative sum
Dynamics the fourth
Frontier is an architected steady state
that gives us the sensation of growth
without requiring external
growth and this sounds Preposterous I
swear I'm not a utopian I'm anti-utopian
I think it is the worst idea humans ever
had so this is a non-utopian idea and
basically just as it is true that inside
your house it is always spring-like it
doesn't violate any laws of physics we
know how we did it right we cooled your
house by heating your
backyard abides by every law of physics
we
know you can create economic well-being
that does not trigger our human impulse
to go after each other by giving us the
feeling that things are growing that we
have just found this new frontier and I
believe that is the only hope for
Humanity is that we will find find that
ability to generate a steady state and
we will understand that we all depend on
its
continuing if we do that it can be
stabilized it's not magical thinking if
we don't if half the world is out to
sabotage it they will succeed frankly
probably if 10% of the world was out to
sabotage it they would succeed so in any
case all right that was a little
long-winded maybe that was two pages
worth of text but it's not the most
complicated answer in the world maybe
it's wrong but I do feel like we are at
a place where we can see the problem and
we can understand Loosely I'm not
telling you I've described how this
thing would be built but I have roughly
described where it would be found where
we should go
look and I don't think we're going to
make it because I think what we're going
to do is we're going to destroy
ourselves here in the very near term
over lineage versus lineage displacement
games that are perfectly predictable and
are back right on
schedule
H so I I like this um let let me let me
hypothesize a fifth Frontier um and this
is going to Dangerously put me into
hippie territory but I speak hippie um I
I I dabbled in in the arts for a while
right um fluent uh but you know this is
the woooo side of thing but um that that
final that other Frontier might be
inward right so we've conquered the
external World arguably we've conquered
space to as much as our chemical
abilities allow us to do with our our
chemical Rockets you know um maybe we
could get a little further but um unless
we break the SpaceTime you know Fifth
Dimension we're kind of stuck here for a
while um and so uh this this inner thing
so so this gets us back to Consciousness
right so I've been I've been wrestling
with this for a long time because I
wanted it to be wrong and I bet a lot of
physicists did too but but the observer
effect in physics is is very well
characterized right and so we understand
now that smallish things electrons
photons are either waves or particles
and the dividing line seems to be was
anybody watching well what do you mean
was anybody watching like could a cat
watch and and would it would it be
different no you have to have this
awareness that you're actually observing
for this thing to be located in space
and when you bring that awareness lo and
behold this thing has always been a
particle even if you do it after it had
to make the decision right it's very
like it it's a brain brain breaker for
me but but it says that there's
something else Happening Here we don't
quite understand and I connect that to
Loosely to this other idea that I've
just been astonished bre by when you
look back through history there are
certain people who seem to have figured
some stuff out and you're like where'd
that come from right like like there
must be some access we have some of us
or maybe all of us that we have to the
greater mystery right that that there is
a way for things awareness information
to be processed that we don't get yet
right and I think Carl Young put it best
I loved how he put it he said people
don't have ideas ideas have
people right and I can find that same
sentiment in in the autobiographies of
Herby Hancock in his music in um
uh who else was saying that um oh Albert
Einstein said the same thing he's like
dude I just I had these crazy ideas and
then I had to find the math to make them
work out you know so where did where did
that where's that come from so I have to
hope somewhere in here that Evolution
has a point of view that it's clearly
experimenting with Consciousness and I
can make a strong argument that if
Consciousness is awareness I can show
you many species that this experiment is
running in not just humans and that
humans are just one of many species that
EV Evolution Nature has said let's try
this Consciousness thing out for some
reason right so what do we do with that
besides bark you know so so I do think
there's something going on here that I I
again I'm I'm standing the older I get
the less I know for sure but I I'm just
now starting to put these pieces
together where I'm starting to
understand that there is on offer for
humans the capability to do some
extraordinarily truly great things that
get us out of our brain stem listen
we're all that more like the tantric
wheel says we're all of these things we
are these vile gross little sub routines
of hardware and wetwear you know that
that sort of evolution gave us and we
also have this capability to step out of
that frame and be these other things too
you know um and and so that's the that's
the moment in in history we find
ourselves in and I think that's the
prime tug of war it's like can we find a
way to break out of our programming so
that we can actually architect things
because I I'll submit to you everybody
listening to this would say I don't want
it to be this way but you know here's
the reality these people have hated each
other for a thousand years so that's
just how it is but but it doesn't have
to be that way right I mean we would
want it to be different so the question
for me is how do we move into this new
state where we can actually manifest
make make real the things that we
actually want rather than the things we
were sort of in that we inherited
however we're using that term beautiful
because this brings us exactly back to
the topic that we put on pause um at the
beginning of the
podcast
so I want to lay on you my model for
Consciousness I will warn you that in
all intellectual endeavors where people
work independently and then team up
there's an inevitable process I don't I
don't think you can particularly
accelerate it you just have to go
through it in
which everybody who works independently
ends up having to redefine and sharpen
and invent terms in order to do the work
because the way that we work in
public the use of a term like
Consciousness is used across so many
different things that it becomes a blunt
instrument that is impossible to do
surgery with so to get back to a
surgical level of precision you have to
redefine it and the thing that I hold
many of my uh intellectual colleagues
responsible for is that they forget that
they did this they don't understand that
they have developed a personal language
that they are then using as if other
people should understand what they're
talking about and so it is their
responsibility to remember that they
speak a personal language and when they
join together my rule is look I don't
care if we use your term for this or my
term right we can just set a a glossery
for our shared work the only requirement
is that everything that is important to
our discussion needs a term to refer to
it we have to agree on what the term is
that refers to it it and um the whole
Space has to be covered
so I will tell you my definition for
Consciousness is not going to be
satisfying because it's going to leave
out what a lot of people mean by it but
there's a reason that I have narrowed it
this way Consciousness is that pack that
portion of cognition that is packaged
for
exchange doesn't mean that you do
exchange it but it's any thought that
you could
report now that is almost exactly
synonymous with it
is subjective
experience your subjective experience is
those things that are noticed in a way
that you could convey them it is not
things like how much force am I going to
put on an adductor muscle to throw a
rock particular distance that's
obviously some kind of neurological
processing but I can't look into that
processing and report it it just sort of
happens I feel it um so with that
definition in mind Consciousness is
subjective experience another way to say
that is that Consciousness is that
portion of cognition that is packaged
for
exchange question evolutionarily that
people struggle over that they swear is
difficult is what the hell is that it
must be many people now conclude it must
be written into the material of the
universe and pre-exists the minds in
which it manifests itself which I think
is nonsense but um I think what they are
missing is the
following what I would argue is an
obvious set of
conclusions the utility of conscious
ious that explains its Evolution and its
nature is not
individual the idea that our that we
have a subjective experience
that exactly overlaps that which we can
report to
others is evidence of what
this paradoxical expensive process is
what it's for and it is not primarily
for thinking thoughts to
ourselves it is in fact advantageous for
that but
secondarily the obvious reason to have
Consciousness is
because the capacity of a group of
people who are not
identical to collectively arrive at
thoughts that are better than the sum
total of what each of them would arrive
that
individually is the stuff of human
well-being so the point this is a little
more halting because I'm fending off
this uh cough from uh four weeks ago but
the um the idea is that human beings
when they face novel circumstances
things for which their ancestors did not
hand them a recipe for use have to
bootstrap a mechanism for dealing with
those novel circumstances and the way
they do it in our our book Heather and I
encode this as campfire they gather
around the campfire when they're not
occupied finding food for the day or
doing other important work when they are
sidelined by the fact that their eyes
are not particularly adjusted to the low
light they gather around the campfire
and they pull their cognitive resources
and they talk about things that they
have noticed they talk about
opportunities they do not know how to
capitalize on and then they parallel
process right if I've seen a creature
that I know has got to be edible but I
don't know how you would catch one then
I might talk about this creature and
where I've seen it and what I know of
its behavior and I might pass that on to
a dozen people some of them may be
Hunters who are too old to pursue game
anymore but know a lot about different
creatures or have passed through some
habitat with other things that might
tell us something about what one might
do to capture one of those things and it
is the parallel processing that makes
human beings so capable of switching
niches this is the thing most creatures
when we say you know what is a
springbok a springb is defined by a
particular Niche that it exists in we
don't find it across a dozen different
niches we find it in one Niche most
species have a niche humans don't have a
niche our Niche is Niche switching it is
the ability to inhabit thousands of
niches simultaneously in different
places with different software packages
without swapping out the hardware right
you same basic
platform but with different uh cultural
packages that enable you to be anything
from a hunter of sea mammals
to a farmer of mountain
Terraces right different software
packages enable different populations
differently and that came about through
we argue this process of
collectively becoming conscious of a
problem and arriving at a solution
through the emergent cognition of
multiple Minds sharing the puzzle
through the magic of language which is
really aside from the fact that we
pretty much understand how it works
magic so anyway um your point about
where we are the interregnum where we
must go the counterintuitive all
suggests to me that what you're looking
for is this is the moment at which we
have
to do whatever the modern campfire thing
is frankly maybe take the
entheogens that are appropriate to that
process to liberate the mind so it is
not so constrained by what it
knows whatever that process is in modern
terms has to happen so that those of us
who are thinking from first principles
can take at least a shot at getting us
out of this puzzle because if there's
one thing that I think any reasonable
person anyone courageous enough to even
confront the question would have have to
admit it's that none of the people who
are driving us seem to know anything
about a long-term plan they may have
plans for how they escape the
catastrophe that's going to befall the
rest of us but nobody seems to have a
plan for all of us
and wouldn't it be a shame if this
marvelous species with all it has
accomplished didn't take at least a
really good shot at architecting a world
in which we
actually could exist a non-utopian world
in which we could be liberated and we
could put aside ancient rivalries and
just simply
be uh our best
selves we can and we we have to because
I I think that's that's the game of foot
right now and so this is where my nature
serves me really well all my nature time
in nature and we're starting to see this
these Str of thinking come out in the
so-called sustainability communities
they don't use the word sustainable
anymore they go with this other word
regenerative because nature is
regenerative and when something is
regenerative in nature it does something
that you have to do it's like the one
thing you have to do you have to create
negative entropy right so this
sunlight's coming down and you're going
to collect that as a tree and you're
going to put that into highly organized
like molecules and relationship and all
of this stuff right because you know
we're we got this metaphor you know
everything tends towards disorder Second
Law it's the law well uh it's not how
nature Works nature takes stuff and
collapses it and and makes negative
entropy out of this meaning highly
ordered things not more disordered
things and that's that's the rule so
anything we've done like oh we have
these sustainable wind towers no we
don't we have these positive net entropy
devices that are going to just wear down
and we're going to have to rebuild them
so they're not alter Alternative Energy
they're rebuildables as Nate Hagen says
it's not that's all they are right so we
haven't yet used our big brains to
figure out how to Fashion something so
that it rebuilds itself over time right
that's what nature does everything it
does it's creating pockets of negative
entropy right and that's that's the rule
so so I can tell whatever the trees are
up to the tree has figured out a way to
do what it does and in 10,000 years you
know all things not going supernova some
spectacular fashion there'll be trees
here right it's so we have to start
thinking about how we how we create
things that are truly regenerative it
begins to me Brett we have to really
appreciate and understand energy and how
energy actually moves and flows that
we've been given this amazing once in a
species bment right you know there's
there's complicated reasons why we have
these things called fossil fuels like we
have coal you know why we have coal
because plants developed lignin before
the back the the the um sorry the fungi
figured out how to break it down there
was this awesome period of several you
know hundred million years or so where
you know in the competing chemistry of
of Life One branch of Life had figured
out how to make stuff that nobody had
figured out how to eat holy moly is that
true yes so it so it built up right
there are no modern coal eras anymore it
just it it's it's the game is is uh is
Advanced beyond that I have been
wondering that for so
long that that's beautiful that's really
marvelous
um yeah all right well among other
things thank you for uh filling in that
piece of my my model of the world um but
I I certainly take your larger point and
I actually think your point about
um windmills
is
fantastic there is something ging about
the idea that this is the sustainable
future never quite adds up and you know
I keep I when I back when I used to
teach I would always point out the
details of you know what is a tree right
it is a you know a self constructing
solar
farm you know that is capable of
spreading across a landscape into places
where the sun is falling in an
underutilized fashion I mean that is
it's so far beyond you know we think of
ourselves is so sophisticated and what
what was here long before we were here
is really
breathtaking right the you know it's
it's Miracles as far as the eye can see
and we clearly are not wise in the sense
that we are not even thinking about why
our technology doesn't doesn't look like
all right our technology should look
like that um or we should figure out how
to live in harmony with the stuff that
already does this really well you think
solar power is good yeah I do let's talk
about plants right they they prove how
good it is and even your fossil fuels
are proof of how good solar power is
because that's what they are they're
just old solar power you know that
happened in a past environment so yeah
there is a
um a certain dirth of wisdom in our
discussions about the future that really
needs to end immediately if we're going
to have a future at all
well I'm struggling with this idea of um
and by the way a lot of these ideas come
from a guy who came to our our recent
honey badger Gathering we hold a yearly
event for Peak Prosperity members here
at the farm and this guy showed up um
and he wasn't on the schedule and within
minutes of talking with him I put him on
the schedule this guy Alan Booker just
amazing amazing polyglot information guy
around regeneration so he was like Wow
wowed me entirely but I started thinking
off of that like what would really
regenerative art architecture look like
for humans you know because it just
things wear down and the closest I could
come up with were were like the Tibetan
monasteries you create a place that has
a narrative in a story and a beauty that
cause people all in their own to show up
and keep that thing going you know it's
got it its own regeneration is built
within its own self right nobody's going
to show up when the strip malls outside
of my town begin to break down nobody's
going to Rally to rebuild them
yeah
no you know as always you're uh so much
of your thinking is
just so instantly resonant for me strip
malls in particular I spent so much time
thinking about how dominant these things
are in our environment and how
Preposterous it is that anybody would I
mean look when people buy a
car they care what it's like on the
inside and maybe they don't buy an
expensive car because they can't afford
it but it's not like anybody is confused
about wanting to be surrounded by things
that are nicer you know everybody would
like a nicer house they would like their
house to be sitting in a place in which
looking out the windows is uh a
rejuvenating experience we all get it
how is it once upon a time architecture
public architecture matter people put up
structures that
actually uh changed the way the
population thought of itself the way it
understood its position in time and for
us to have created these just
appallingly ugly structures that do
reveal our inner ugliness at such a
profound level it's like it's like a
surrender to um I don't know self
self-destruction or self-mutilation
it's Preposterous and you're right
nobody would rally to them but what
about a place that um that you actually
felt some sense of pride in the fact
that you had gotten to live there and
that it would be there long after you
were gone and that it would matter to
someone else that you hadn't met and
that they might wonder about you just
based on the fact that they knew someone
else lived here 500 years ago what would
they have thought right that it's such a
more um
powerful vision of what a human being is
in its environment that it's amazing
that we surrendered it so
easily it is and and I think I had early
environmentalism sort of as a disease
you know thinking of humans as this
blight and we're not we're we're just a
highly invasive species and here we are
right um we have the
capability uh to use our big brains for
extraction and depletion or we can use
them for re regeneration and and
rebuilding and so you know our our whole
goal here on on our farm is very the
reason we have cows there are soil
management experts they're brilliant we
don't know how they do it but they they
improve things right so that's it we're
just here to make the soil better and
whether the people who come after us
choose to see it that way and maintain
it or not I don't know but if they do
that's an actual Legacy that will pass
on and they don't have to know my name
and it's not about indiv individual
Legacy but I've noticed Brett that when
you step onto a place where the people
have cared for it in a very loving
fashion and have mostly just worked with
to help it be a better form of itself
because we can that's what we can use
this for is to help speed things along
we can help nature create top soil at
100 to 400 times its native rate right
great um when you step onto a property
that's managed that way it's just
instantly obser I I just know it right
there's certain Farms you walk on you're
just like oh okay this is work it just
it's immediately obvious that this is
correct correct and right and true um
just as immediately obvious as that ior
mechon works I mean there's just some
things you just know right
away you know and and so I think it's as
simple and as hard as that it's
empowering people to step away from the
old story and this and and what's the
new story well let's get busy being
regenerative I don't know what happens
next I can't control any of that I don't
know um I have
worries but I think the best I can do is
is just um you know set it up put put
the ball put the ball on the te for the
next team you know I think that's as
close as I can
get um interesting that you say all this
uh Heather and I have moved to the San
Juan Islands and we live in a place
that's very different than any place
we've ever lived
before it's weird it has a strangely
Short history in geological terms
because what formed the saor sea and
left the islands that remain here
here was a glaciation that ended 15,000
years ago and effectively there was a
giant mile thick sheet of ice that sat
in this location and when it melted the
erosion carried a lot of loose material
out into the Pacific and the rocky
material remained and those are the
islands that we live
on so 15,000 years isn't a long history
for Iraq right now this particular
particular set of rocks had a native
population on it
um and that population if you know how
to look at the
place radically altered
Landscapes they transformed them
into
utterly
beautiful self- sustaining
regenerating places and so
we live in a former fishing camp the
evidence of it is there if you know how
to look there are middens where huge
amounts of shellfish were processed they
were taking advantage of the massive
salmon runs that came through here and
um and
maintaining prairies where there would
have been
forest in any case um you don't
initially know that that's what it is
the first time you see it you just think
it's a pretty place
but then the more you learn
about how it was altered and you know
it's it's sad that these people are not
there but that their work
remains and that it is
not it's the opposite of a strip mul man
it's it is a testament to their uh
facility that they were able to
transform landscapes in a way that
wasn't just bulldozing stuff
right they they made something and
something
remarkable and I think about it all the
time I mean we we bike through these
habitats and we see their work and feel
a connection to them and
um and anyway it does give you a kind of
exactly as you say it doesn't matter
that they know your
name as
they as they utilize the soil that you
improved through your labor on your farm
really doesn't matter at all your name
is irrelevant but that they might stop
to think that somebody who was wise had
this piece of land and did something
with it um with a thought about how they
would take advantage of it later you
know you're right it does sound a little
hippie if you're not used to thinking
these ways but on the other hand it's
like look okay you got a choice the
hippies were crazy I mean we know this
they became Boomers they were not uh
dispropor proportionately wonderful
people who had tapped into the way that
we could all live in a nicer fashion
treating each other better that's just
not who they were
but such
things such
people have
existed and we have a choice we can
either figure out how to tap into that
kind of
longterm thinking that
wisdom or we can wreck our ourselves and
the thing that makes
me really concerned for the place I now
live is that I worry that not only are
we going to foolishly destroy ourselves
which I think is pretty
likely but that we're going to
destroy all of the
stuff that
exists the whales that swim
by The Eagles that hunt the the gulls
and the salmon all of these things are
fragile and we've in fact jeopardized
all of them and in that jeopardized
State and in our arrogance to think only
of what we might do about the next five
minutes rather than thinking about
what's our plan for the next 500
years um we threaten to
undo the work of people who did think
about their impact on on the land and
that I don't know I guess probably in
the Scale of the Universe it's such a
tiny tragedy that it doesn't matter but
given that this is the only planet we
know of that looks like
this the tragedy is not it cannot be
small to us even if we take ourselves
out which I truly hope we don't because
I do think humans are in many ways the
most special thing that has ever
happened here the place was plenty
special without us and um it would be
such a shame if our arrogance wrecked it
on the way
out well I guess true and if we manage
to wipe out everything but but one vent
you know in the deep ocean life will
come back um give it 10 million years or
100 or something it will find a way so
um but my my grief is such that that uh
I think it's beautiful and I think it's
it's unseemly to destroy things of
beauty I think that's you know that
that's just always wrong right um and
so to me nature is beautiful the thing
that fills me with Dread bread is is
that you know and I tell this to people
and lot lot of time light bulbs go off
it's the windshield moment like when I
was a kid our windshields when you drove
from A to B would get just coated with
insects you know yeah and now you can
drive literally across the country and
maybe never have to clean your
windshield once you know for of insects
right could be other dust on there
something and so this is a 480 million
year old food chain and we are wiping it
out in nobody has a single clue what the
emergent effect of that is going to be
we don't know we just don't know but I
would I would say a little humility
there would be awesome and we should
rewind our clock and say when did this
start like right around mid 80s like
anything we introduced since the 80s is
off the market till we figure this out
right that would be an intelligent
response you know oh don't I ever and in
fact this was uh I remember well our
first conversation and that fact the
change in the windshield from you're
you're a bit older than I am
but uh not terribly much um when I was a
kid the windshield I mean it you know it
was a problem there were special
products that you could you know put in
the windshield wiper fluid thing of your
uh car and they didn't work particularly
well because the insects were pretty
gooey and you know it was a thing it was
a problem um and then at some point I
don't know when I first noticed it but
it's like like
hey where' they go
like we're talking about a huge
transformation of the way the biology of
planet Earth functions and it just
vanished and I will say that there's one
other piece of this which I think is is
hopeful if you had told
me that we were going to crash that 400
million year is that what you said 400
million year
uh 480 million year um food web I would
have said that that would potentially be
an extinction level
failure that at least you would get
massive starvation out of it and that
obviously didn't
happen I think what did happen is we got
a radical
reduction in the active diversity of
these
things um but
somehow the plants that we
eat um were not dependent on the
creatures that were destroyed something
so anyway if You' asked me what would
happen if such a change occurred I would
have thought it less recoverable than it
obviously is likewise if you had told me
that we would hunt sea otters down to a
population of less than 100 or elephant
seals or
Eagles or Condors if you had told me
that these things would reach this
precarious edge of
Extinction I might have told you that I
thought the likelihood that they would
reemerge and create a sustaining self-
sustaining population was near zero and
I would have been wrong about that too
so in any case I I I do worry that
people will look at how much damage
we've already done and they'll think ah
screw it it's too late and it is too
late for some stuff you know the uh
Tasmanian wolf will never roam the Earth
again but um but there's so much left to
be saved and you know I do as as I know
you do I believe a beautiful non-utopian
liberating world is possible if we can
embrace the counterintuitive and embrace
your call for us
to uh confront this puzzle together and
perhaps you know run the risk of
sounding foolish in exploring what might
be
done and I I would default it all the
way back to the metaphor level and um
I'll here I'll get in trouble um here's
here's the metaphor that's wrong humans
are special and different
I'll I'll get in trouble say no we're
not we we are a part of a very special
thing like if you know what the jewel
was does in its predation of the
Cockroach or if you understand like you
know just how aggressive uh plants are
at shading each other out and and just I
mean just watching all of life we we can
be special but but where I would submit
that we're on a par with like we're a
part of this well we're part of this uh
computational machine that's solving the
mysteries of life and all of that right
you know so I'm I just I just want to
leave I hope that we can leave space for
enough other organisms so that we don't
accidentally create a whole lot of
Extinction ours and others right and
there's a Extinction is the technical
moment when there's no more surviving
species and you can't resurrect them but
there's functional Extinction which you
know is is the layer before that where
there are some but not enough to get
things going again you know in a
meaningful way um so I hope that that we
can figure this out before we get there
you know and and I'm very encouraged
though Brett by seeing a lot of younger
people in particular who are like
they're getting you know they want to be
part of this real regenerative sort of
um landscape and I think they deserve
all our support I wish that instead of
100 billion going to Ukraine we would
have a billion going into these sorts of
activities but we don't have those as
priorities yet in this country you know
the priorities are still let's blow up
some people let's make more money for
banksters let's put in some more strip
malls we still have this narrative
running and we're not putting anything
really in this other direction yet and I
don't know what it takes to get us over
there um but maybe it's just getting
people out of this demoralized state of
shrugging and going well that's just how
it is what are you going to do you know
I got elected to congress but I couldn't
dare promote any of that stuff because
then I I won't get in again or whatever
the stories are um that's what we need
to do at this point is create space for
people who are doing this stuff uh to do
it and you know I would encourage any
body listening one key way you do that
is you you pay a little more for your
food because it ca takes a lot of energy
to grow it and you buy it from those
bright shiny kids up the road who are
trying and they're building soil and
relationships with each other and with
nature as they do that right you
know time to vote I love that people
voted against Bud Light and Disney films
and all that stuff but let's vote for
too yeah people are doing it
right uh I I agree with that I am going
to take the risk of taking the exact
opposite position that you have taken um
and I'm going to do it for a reason and
then I'm going to give you the last word
and I feel like we are at a good place
to to wrap this up but you have
said and I don't disagree with what
you've said that human beings are not
special I'm going to take the position
that human beings
are highly
special and that if we in fact look at
that highly special nature of human
beings that we in fact arrive at exactly
the same correct place that we arrive if
we take your your proposal that we are
not special so the way in which we are
special is that we are
capable of
appreciating our position in the
universe we are capable of appreciating
the Marvel of the things that exist on
this planet with us and in the cosmos
with us uniquely as far as we know we
know of no other creature that can do
this and even more amazing we are
capable not of just appreciating these
things in isolation but of co-
appreciating them and of extrapolating
collectively together about the meaning
of these
incredible Mysteries that surround us
these these Miracles that are
our everyday experience and that that is
a
profound it is a profound gift to be a
member even briefly of a species in
which you can do that to be alive is an
incredible thing but to be able to
understand what it is to be alive and
why it is incredible and what the other
things that are alive are and you know
even mundane things like having a a pet
effectively a friend that is a member of
a different species where you don't know
exactly what they think of the world but
you can certainly infer a lot about what
it must be right this is an incredible
an incredible opportunity that we just
do not Savor well enough and my point
about if you decide that human beings
are not special as you're
suggesting then you would naturally want
to priori PR ize the other things on
this planet and protect them in their
own
right if you decide that human beings
are
ultimately profoundly special you
actually arrive in the same place and I
think a little bit more securely
because if I say this is a marvelous
Planet full of incredible Miracles that
have nothing to do with
us maybe I even argue that those things
have rights to exist and that we have no
right to destroy them it's certainly an
argument that I resonate with
emotionally but what do I do with the
anopheles
mosquito it is as miraculous as any
other
creature but I want to drive it extinct
for the well-being of people and I can't
if I decide that it and small poox and
you
know pathogens that infect our every
organ if I decide that these things are
as important as I am then I'm in no
position philosophically to address them
on the other hand if I say to
myself that the specialness of humans
our ability to appreciate what it is to
be alive and to be in the universe and
to be on this beautiful planet if I if I
look at that as fundamental then the
answer is well now I know what to do I
know what it is that I am actually
obligated to protect and I know what it
is that I must actually
maybe with no joy in my heart but drive
to
extinction because my real obligation
philosophically is to take that
marvelous opportunity to be a thinking
collaborative human being on this
beautiful planet and to provide it to as
many people going forward as can
possibly be given that gift to deny
anyone the experience of being here who
might live and won't get to is
a
loss we would not want to have been
denied this experience and we do not
have the right to deny it to those in
the future and so anyway it tells me
that uh I'm obligated to protect the
giant Pacific octopus
and the Orca
and the polar
bear but I'm not obligated to protect
the anop mosquito so in any case uh I
don't I don't know what you'll do with
that but I'm interested to
hear well thank you thanks for that
thanks for the for the last word um
which won't be but
um I actually think that that this idea
of um not special is is the portal to
get us to where we need to go and the
reason I think that is that um a a an
executive coach Dropped a Bomb on Me a
long time ago she wasn't my coach but
but she I was explaining how she worked
with people and so she works with CEOs
and the CEOs need to be better humans so
then manage better and make better
decisions and find more time in the day
she said she lets them burn through that
usually within you know a number of
weeks to months she gets them to the
point where she can maneuver them to say
actually what you're seeking is
happiness you're seeking contentment and
that the Gateway word for that is
enough once you know you have enough you
can be satisfied and all of a sudden
Things become clear and so this thing
you're talking about this evolutionary
impulse There Is Never Enough Bill Gates
operates from a scarcity model right you
know he still needs more for some reason
right wasn't enough had to put 500
million into you know Buy in Tech stock
because he needed more um and and so
this idea of humans not being special
Gets You Through hopefully this portal
of saying actually we are we might have
special responsibilities because we have
special capabilities but there's no
there's nothing out there assuring that
humans are protected right this
exceptionalism because if the plants all
go away if all photosynthesis stops
we're not that special after all it
turns out you know in a very short
amount of time right there are things
you know if if those steps in in Russia
decide to you know burp lava over a few
hundred thousand square kilometers again
and and you know the whole our
atmosphere becomes acidic like it did at
one of the boundaries Extinction
boundaries were not special right so but
that's but that idea is that once you
realize that we're just a part of
something and we're in this great flow
and it's this great mystery and we'll
never know our hardware and software is
incapable of actually processing what's
happening and when people take certain
you know medicine plants and the filters
come down you realize just how complex
those filters are to help us make sense
of of this energetic World we're
actually inhabiting for for a brief time
so so that I think it's it's that lack
of specialness for me sitting under that
is this IDE of this humility again but
that with humility is that ability to
actually begin to really engage with
what's out there because awe to me awe
is is a felt sense I can't put it into
words but I'm awed special sunsets
moments birth of a child there's just
this thing it's a it's a felt sense
right so I I do think this is an
invitation at this moment in time if we
can let go of our our exceptionalism you
know that that we're owed something that
that we that somehow just by being human
we do something I don't think that's
true right Ben Franklin said most people
die by the age of 25 they're just not
buried till they're 75 right because
they've given up on engaging in in life
and so so to me that that's what this
whole invitation is about this period of
time when the old story is breaking down
what a great time to sit back and
re-evaluate and say what's this all
about and to say what you said which is
this is an extraordinary thing to be
alive to even to have the to be sensing
this in this moment with you this is
It's extraordinary it really is and I
think our culture is militating against
all of that they want us distracted
confused angry Disturbed whatever these
things are but these are emotional
states that take us out of really
engaging with life I would submit um and
so yeah identify
and let's move past that I think that's
the challenge we have right now so there
that's that's beautiful and I do want it
to be the last word I'll just tell you
one thing I got from
it um this concept of enough if you put
modern people in the context of what we
once had and what we now have and take
for granted you realize our enough
circuit is broken and it's broken for
evolutionary reasons because we're
pursuing opportunities that our
ancestors didn't have so we're focused
on what we might have that we don't
rather than focused on what we do have
but we have to get in touch with the
concept of
enough agreed agreed
well let's let's keep this convers I've
so I've got 400 more questions and
comments but let's save it so y now this
has been it's been a fantastic
conversation as always Chris I uh I
never know where our conversations are
going and I uh cherish each one of them
and I certainly hope that
people uh have gotten as much from this
as I did it was really really good so uh
we'll do it again soon and uh thanks for
joining me well great I have you on the
books to come and be on on my show
because we need our audiences to find
each other because the Beast is keeping
them apart from each other and so we
should we should introduce them yeah as
much as possible absolutely and they
will find it's interesting that there's
not more overlap but they will find each
other uh fellow travelers to be
certain so indeed my audience should
find you at Peak prosperity.org
uh it should find you at your Twitter
handle
is Chris Martinson Chris Martinson you
want to spell
Martinson m a r t n s o n Martenson
right um okay and what else you've got
your crash course which people if they
want to come to understand uh the nuts
and bolts of where they are in history
would be a great place for people to go
umh and what else well the there's the
that's the problem definition the
companion book is um uh Prosper which
talks about building eight different
forms of capital up Finance is one but
so is um emotional Capital so that uh if
you're rich in all eight forms of
capital you'll be more resilient so so
really we're about resilience and Peak
Prosperity uh obviously you know I put
my my own stuff there a lot um that's
where my content goes but it's what it
really is BR it's a community of people
we got a lot of people back there and
and they're no surprise right we we're
curious we're freethinking um we have
very civil discourse uh there are a lot
of overly represented successful humans
in life um who kind of are on the vibe
that maybe now is we we better start um
becoming resilient so so that's how that
everything I do is in service of of
helping people um see what's coming
before it comes and and the good news is
the community has now a level of
intelligence built around that that's um
I'm I'm astonished at how smart our
community is it's an amazing thing
that's fantastic and at the end of the
day um that matters so much more than
all of the noise that one experiences
out in the world
MH all right um well it's been a
pleasure and uh not only thank you for
joining me but I want to thank everybody
who uh hung in there with this wide
ranging and I think important
conversation so uh be well
everybody well thank you Brett I
appreciate it i' I've been looking
forward to this all week and it exceeded
All my expectations and hopes so perfect
thank you for this opportunity all right
see you soon all right bye
everyone
[Music]